Hello everybody!
Hello everyone.
We are here for the Season 20 Apex launch.
There's a lot of big changes going on here.
And despite everything...
Sorry, I'm like super rusty.
I haven't played Apex in a long time!
Oh my god.
But a lot of things have changed for this game.
And I'm like, honestly, I'm like really, really excited to actually play the official release of it.
Because like, I playtested this release a long time ago.
And I can fi- I've been keeping it a secret for a while.
So, it's so cool that it's finally out.
And for those who are wondering what the biggest change is, like the MOBA shit they did.
Where basically, you can- your armor is connected to your upgrades.
So you can pick one or the other.
So like, I've seen this for a while now.
So I'm- so I debated about streaming today.
But I've- I just want a game.
I just- I didn't obviously, due to the circumstances, I didn't sleep a lot.
I think I had like, three hours of sleep.
And then I've been- I've been awake for a while now.
I was like, uh, do I- do I- do I- do I do?
And honestly, gaming has always been like, a huge comfort for me.
And especially Apex.
Apex is like, one of my biggest comfort games.
And like, no matter- oh my go- I'm sorry.
No matter what happens, like, I always default to Apex.
Because it really- oh my gosh.
It has like, helped me a lot.
Like, dealing with my emotions.
Because I just- especially Apex.
Because Apex has always been my ultimate comfort game.
Whenever I- I'm sad.
Um, Apex has always helped me a lot.
Especially if I'm playing Apex with people.
Um, and it really helps me a lot.
In general.
So, that's why I decided, I was like, I'll stream Apex.
And I didn't want to be alone.
And I want to say a huge shoutout to all my friends that- stayed up with me last night.
Um, making sure I was safe.
Um, and all people.
Making sure I was safe.
Making sure, um, everything was okay.
So I just wanted to say- I can't really, um, say who they are publicly.
But I just wanted to say, like, a huge thank you.
Um, to all my friends that- stayed up with me last night.
And just to make sure I had people, uh, around.
So I'd be okay.
And everything.
And that's why I also wanted to stream today!
I wanted to stream because- Um, I didn't really want to be alone.
And I've always enjoyed playing Apex.
Uh, I always enjoyed playing Apex.
And it's- like I said, it's something- Something I've enjoyed doing.
And always cheers me up.
And for those- Obviously I can't say much about the current situation.
Um, because, uh, my lawyer is making sure I'm safe.
So, um, I can't really say much.
For now, I just wanna- Pew pew!
I have not played Apex in a long time!
So, it's gonna be rough.
It's gonna be very fucking rough.
Obviously.
Uh, so, I'm gonna get shit on.
Especially when I feel like- There's a lot- Oh shit, there's a lot of people coming back right now.
And I feel so rusty at the moment.
Um, so yeah.
Uh, yeah, anyway.
I heard like- Okay, I don't really remember a lot of the upgrades.
But this one was like, you can see batteries and stuff.
And then increases tactical range.
Gain a tactical charge but have shield regen duration.
Like, shit like that.
Like, that shit.
Like, you can't find armors on the ground anymore apparently.
Um, so...
That- I don't know!
I guess like that makes it so it's less lucky.
Like, it's less RNG.
So you can't find armor on the ground anymore.
And, uh, it's all about like upgrading your armor.
Yeah, like shooting your gun.
Or like finding like XP boxes.
Like these XP boxes and shit that will get you like free upgrade.
And stuff like that.
Or like abilites or something.
It is very- It looks different.
Yeah, like this new season is a lot of changes.
And apparently rank, it resets everybody to like 0 or 1.
Sorry, 1.
So every rank starts off at rank 1 or rank 1 point.
Sorry, not rank 1.
But- But like starts off at rank 1.
Like, like So rank 1 is at 1 point.
So Preds will be in the same lobby as like Bronze players and shit like that.
Which is like, sucks to the Bronze players.
And then like, I remember I was telling one of my friends.
I was like, I was like, Oh my go- I was like, Oh my god no!
We're gonna- Like, what if we- What if we get in a game with all these Pred players?
And then my friend was like, I was like, you do know the percentage of Pred players in the Apex population, right?
And I was like, wait... and then they were like, yeah, there's more...
There's more gold Plat players playing this game than there are Pred players.
You do know that, right?
I was like, oh my god, wait!
I forgot Pred is 1% of the fucking population!
So like... I was like, oh my god, there's real people playing this game.
It's been a... you know, after being in like, SPMM lobbies for so long...
I forgot there were like, actual people that played this game and not the degen lowlifes like me.
I was like, oh my god!
There's a dad out there!
There's a dad out there who just got home from work!
That's booting up his face!
He's like, I'm gonna get my favorite Apex Legends game that's like in bronze right now!
And then he's gonna get absolutely farmed!
I was like, holy shit!
They exist!
Look, I've been in like, SPMM lobbies for so fucking long now.
For those who don't know what SPMM is, it's like...
I don't remember the full names.
That was something... match...
What was it called?
Okay, I don't even remember the full name.
But it's basically like, matchmaking where you're in the lobby with your skill level.
Sorry, my brain's not working when you're going around with three hours of sleep.
So I forgot what it's like to play with and against real people and with jobs.
Who have like, 9 to 5 jobs.
And like, is playing this game as a hobby.
And is also not a freak... controller, roller demon freak.
I forgot what that is.
Like, oh skill based matchmaking, yes.
That's what I mean.
I forgot that's what it was like.
So I was like, holy... but this is only in rank though.
Like, I'm gonna be playing some trios.
I don't know why I won't play rank.
Because I don't want to get farmed by...
I don't want to be the dad that gets farmed by the friend play.
And so...
So like, I was like, oh... that's... nah.
So... we're just gonna do some trios.
But yeah, I know there's like...
Oh shit, how do I change heroes again?
It's been a while.
Oh, M.
Alright, oh, you can tell how long...
When was the last time I've touched this account.
I saw like Octane has some cool ones.
Did my game crash?
Oh, that was a problem.
Whoops.
Alright.
Huh?
Apex?
Are you okay?
Hello?
Guys, I think I broke Apex.
Give me a sec.
I think Apex was like, no.
You cannot play Octane.
Let me force quit this real fast.
Alright, so apparently...
I'm gonna have to go back to the game.
Apex did not like that I tried to play...
That I...
I tried to play Octane just now.
Apex was like, no, no, no.
You cannot show the world the Octane stats.
Oh my god, how do I get my task manager back here?
Task messenger!
How do I get you over here?
Okay, guys.
We have a little situation.
Okay, wait.
What was the...
Guys, what is the thing that force quits again?
What was the keyboard shortcut?
Guys.
Guys, what's the keyboard shortcut?
You know when you're like, hey guys, I need tech support.
And you always say that thing that never fixes the game.
But...
Oh, Alt F4.
There we go.
Alt F...
I hope I don't Alt F4 my fucking OBS.
That would be very unfortunate.
Oh, no, I didn't.
But it's not for...
Oh my god.
How do I fix this?
Okay, guys.
What is that...
What is that shortcut that lets me move my browser to another monitor?
Sorry, I need to call tech support real quick.
I can't believe picking Octane fucked up my game.
What was the thing that makes it so that it'll move to my other monitor?
I don't remember.
I don't remember what moves my shit to the other monitor.
Alright.
Ctrl Alt Shift...
Wait, that doesn't sound right.
Window Shift Left.
Okay.
That sounds right.
Window Shift Left.
Oh!
There we go.
Alright.
It says not responding.
I did it.
I force quit Apex.
Oh my god.
You know, to be fair, the game did just launch.
So, like, I ain't gonna blame it.
It is...
It is launch day.
So, I'm not surprised that the game was like, no.
Alright.
Let's see.
Apex.
Yay!
Alright.
I guess we're not even gonna...
I guess the game doesn't want me to play Octane even though, like, I heard Octane's powerups were pretty cool.
I think I wrote...
From what I remember from the playtest, it was...
He gets, like, an extra jump or some shit.
I don't really remember too much.
Alright, so, like, I could play rank.
But then, like, I don't really...
I don't know.
I don't wanna get farmed right now.
Cause every fucking pro player out there is playing rank right now.
Every fucking streamer and every pro is playing.
And, like, I know, like, they're, like, 5% of the player base.
But, like, it's still...
They're still there.
If I get into a lobby where it's filled with, like, bronzes and stuff.
Because players... and they're like the only pro team out there, like... they're just gonna run it down and fuck me up.
Like... it's... five percent is still five percent of the lobby.
Usually, usually they'll just run around killing everybody, and I don't want to be part of... I don't want to be part of their statistic.
Alright.
I'm pretty sure I'll get the five percent.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure...
I'm not really feeling it unless I have a three stack.
Oh my god I get to actually show my badges!
I haven't seen those badges in forever!
Oh my god, I haven't seen those badges in so long.
I told you guys!
I told you guys I had them!
I knew it!
I knew I wasn't full of cope.
Alright.
What is my upgrade?
So it takes 25% less stim damage.
Where the fuck I'll never get nated!
Oh shit.
Okay.
You can tell the game just came out.
Guys guys, no you don't understand this game.
This game just came out guys.
You don't understand.
I have not played Octane in so long.
I just know like his stuff is like fun.
Alright.
Zero guns.
Oh no.
Nice.
Okay.
Let me like... I always forget to fix my bindings.
Did he steal my loot?
What the fuck are you doing?
Oh shit.
I'm fucked.
I don't really have the guns right now.
Hello.
Oh shit!
You're not my teammate!
Oh!
No!
I thought I was my... Oh shit.
Sorry.
That was... Yikes.
I did not... What the fuck?
I did not expect like two people to be there.
They can play like a team?
What do you mean?
Where's my team?
To be fair I was... What the fuck is wrong with you?
I'm already dead!
Oh my god!
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Leave me alone!
Oh my god!
You dog shit!
You can't even throw a screen!
That's so annoying.
That's so boring.
Look.
Sorry.
This was a warm up round.
I'm not... You know.
I was so...
Sorry.
That was just... That was just... Look.
If he had trouble like trying to kill me while I was already down...
That's on him.
Look.
I told you!
I'm like the dad that just got home getting farmed!
This is why... This is why I don't play... I'm not playing rank right now.
I have no idea what I'm doing.
It's been too long.
Oh this guy knows what he's doing.
He knows the climb up.
He already knows more than 90% of the player base.
Oh.
Oh!
Movement.
Movement right there.
Wait!
Tony!
Where the fuck were you?
Why didn't you come and save me earlier?
You clearly know what you're doing.
But also, why the fuck are you playing Seer?
Is Seer OP now?
Also, Tony should be the one stream... I'm just... I'm just a Tony POV streamer now.
Oh.
No armor swaps.
Whoa.
Where the fuck am I?
No!
Pick me up!
I'm so helpful!
I swear to god I'm Octane.
You know I'm useful.
No!
Stoky bird!
Well, I don't give a fuck about Tony anymore.
There's no... There's no reasons.
Oh shit!
Gumi, okay.
Wait, Gumi, if you're watching...
Let me play like five more solos and then I'll come over.
I don't know if she's watching.
Alright, what are some... Okay, guys.
Tell me who has the best upgrades.
Alright, who has the best upgrades, guys?
Who is it?
I'll just keep her up here.
Alright.
Tony did not want... Yeah, they did not want to save me.
So they don't get the streamer POV now.
Who has the best one?
Watson?
I swear to god it's not... I swear to god it's because...
Oh wait, Watson has a thing where like...
Did he keep the one where like if you...
His like gas canister heals him and shit?
Did he keep that?
Yeah!
Oh wait!
Wait, what about Bangalore?
There was one more...
Yeah!
I remember this.
That shit was so OP.
Basically, if I... If I'm in the Bangalore smoke, I reject...
I mean, I'm literally reading what it says.
I don't know what I'm... I don't know what I'm telling you guys.
You guys can read and like...
Yeah, like, you know, there's smoke, my HP comes back.
Like...
So like... I don't know if they like nerfed it or whatever, but it was so fucking overpowered during the playtest.
It was so bad during the playtest.
Everyone was just playing... Everyone was just... I remember in the playtest, it was like...
They were... My team was like Bangalore, Caustic, and Lifeless.
And I was like, I'm gonna die.
Or something, because it was so dumb.
We just healed each other.
We were just self-healing each other non-stop.
No!
My Bangalore!
What the fuck was the point after I fucking bragged about Bangalore?
I'll play Pathfinder.
Okay, what do we have?
Gain access, gain access... Oh shit, Pathfinder's fucking dog shit.
He has nothing.
Why do I care about like, beacons or whatever?
Why do I care about intel?
I'm gonna die anyway.
Can't believe it.
My game crashed.
Oh, thank god.
I guess...
I guess the game...
The game was like, you don't wanna play Pathfinder?
I guess you don't have to play.
Oh my god.
Apex is not what I mean!
I still wanna play the game!
What the fuck, Apex?
I still wanna play!
The game was like, how dare you.
I wonder if I'll still be in the lobby.
My poor guy.
It's alright.
He was chanting.
He's a champion.
He can survive.
I swear to god, if I load in, I'm dead.
I s- Oh, thank god.
Oh, this is- I don't like being here.
Oh wait, I'm still fine.
Oh no, I have my fucking heirloom on.
Yes, back in the day, I- Sorry about the frames.
It's- It's- It gets like that when you log back in.
Alright.
Yes, back in the day, I used to spend money.
Um...
And- But Pathfinder heirloom has to be one of the fucking worst heirlooms out there.
I've like, realized because it's so fucking...
Um...
It's just so annoying- Like, it takes up too much of the screen!
It just takes up too much of the screen.
And hate- I don't like the Pathfinder heirloom.
Alright.
Alright!
Son!
You have your fucking regen HP!
I follow you because I think you know what you're doing.
Where are they?
I don't know where they are.
Hello?
Oh.
Oh, our guy.
Our average everyday.
You okay?
He's over there.
Ooh!
Nice.
That was fast.
Poor guy.
Yay!
You had no friends.
Poor guy.
He didn't have stun.
Cool gloves?
Thank you.
It's- It takes up 80% of my screen.
It takes up- This is why, like- Like, Master plus players don't have their heirlooms out anymore.
Oh my god.
Wow!
I guess- Who cares?
I don't need intel.
Who the fuck uses intel?
What the fuck?
Where?
Oh shit!
Okay, there he is.
I didn't know he was there.
Wait, what?
Did he come downstairs?
Where is he?
Wait, what?
I- Oh god, I'm dying, deadslid.
Where is he?
Where the fuck are these people?
Oh!
It's okay, I killed a TTV-er.
Come on, stun!
Reach in!
Reach in and you're sm- Oh, he's dead.
Look, I swear, I- All I'm saying is that if I was on Bangalore, I would've lived.
I would've fucking lived.
Okay, all I'm gonna say is that as a streamer, I blamed my heirloom.
I feel like I should unlock all these guys real quick.
Let me...
I don't unlock again.
It's been so long.
I don't want to...
I don't want to unlock...
I don't want to unlock characters.
Guys!
Where the fuck is the unlock button?
There's a bio now?
There's lore?
Okay, that's too much to read.
I can't...
Guys, it's been too long!
Money?
There's no way it's money now.
Even I can't unlock him anymore?
Oh, right...
Oh my god.
Wait, no?
What the fuck happened?
It used to be so simple!
Unlocking characters used to be so simple.
When did it get so difficult for all the dads out there?
You have to buy the buy button?
Oh my gosh, there he is.
Wait, do I not have Fuse?
Why is it locked?
Oh, challenge is coming soon!
I'm so stupid.
Sorry, I can't...
I don't...
I can't see.
I was like, why is it locked?
I was like, I thought I bought Fuse.
Like 20 years ago.
I already have...
Sorry.
I'm a stupid dad.
I'm sorry.
I told you.
It's been...
It's been so long since I've touched...
Since I've touched Apex.
Alright, now.
Don't worry, guys.
It's not...
It's always a warm up until I win.
I told you!
Donkey can't read.
Alright, here we go.
Cat, this is what I have you guys for!
You guys are supposed to backseat me.
What the fuck?
You guys had one fucking job.
Alright, this time.
Okay, okay, this...
Why would I get to play fucking Rengar?
I don't wanna play Pathfinder!
But also, please don't crash my game again, Apex.
Please don't do it.
I can't believe it.
I wasn't paying attention.
Holy shit, it's so hot in my room.
Let me open the window real quick.
Alright, I'm back.
Are we always going to Fragment again?
Guys!
Guys, come on!
I would love to go Fragment, but I'm on Pathfinder.
Oh my god, I actually have like, trails...
Like, not trails, but like the animation and shit.
Oh my god!
Please tell me I'll find a gun.
Because I think I fucked up.
Oh!
Guys, do you guys have a gun?
I'll punch him!
Okay, I'm gonna leave.
I don't think I have a gun.
Oh!
Wait, there's nobody here.
Whoa!
Is there guns anywhere?
Guys!
Oh, wait, he's 20.
Oh!
There's a lot of people here.
I'm just...
I'm just gonna go down here for a little bit.
Whoa!
Hey guys!
Oh my god!
Just chill a little bit.
Gun?
Nice.
Okay.
Sorry, I had to go through finding one singular gun.
Hello?
Anybody here?
Alright, nope.
Where the fuck is everybody?
It's okay, I found a gun.
My one gun.
Whoa!
Hello?
Oh my gosh.
Where are you?
Hello?
Where the fuck are you?
Where the fuck are people?
From like 500 people to zero?
This is add up.
Oh, oh, I hear him.
Hello?
Cracked him.
Oh, fuck, I'm stunned.
No!
Please, it's one guy!
There's no way you get fucked over by one...
Okay, there you go.
Okay.
It's okay.
We didn't get fucked over by one guy.
Oh, thank God.
Wait, there's regen now?
Oh my God, nice.
Okay, I got that.
My core in.
I almost jumped into that.
It's okay.
I'm slowly...
I won't say waking up, because I've been awake for a long time, but my eyes are not blurring together now.
Oh, thank God.
None of these matter.
I don't want Pathfinder's life.
This is like the shittiest upgrade.
Like, who...
I'm not playing Reign.
All right.
Oh, wait, zero bullets.
That's all right.
I never needed my Mastiff, I guess.
Did I sleep?
That's a good question.
I can say that I slept three hours.
What the fuck are you doing, Bangalore?
You had regen.
Oh, poor guy.
Oh, he had regen, too.
Where is he?
Wait, he's double regening.
Oh, he's double regening.
That's illegal.
Wait.
Oh, fuck.
I don't know where the fuck he is, but he's just regening.
There we go.
No, he's dead!
Stop!
He's dead!
Now I'm fucking stunned.
Okay.
Where is...
Oh, wait, they already rez'd.
Fuck, okay.
Where do I go?
Oh, I'm stuck.
What is that?
King?
Evil Harvester?
What is...
Where are these fancy buttons on my map?
Alright.
Wait.
Where the fuck is the...
That's energy.
Okay.
I'm just like, where are all these fancy icons on my map?
And I'm so confused.
Everyone's playing Seer.
I wonder what Seer has.
Guys, that's like so good.
Yay.
Oh, I could've...
Same though...
Wait!
What?
Do I know you?
Oh, shit!
This is your fault, Miko!
Oh, my god.
Why are you...
Niko you fucking... I swear to god!
Niko you bitch!
Oh shit.
Okay I would help you but like... I'm scared.
What does he mean?
The most interesting part is that he said from four years ago.
Niko!
It's like...
Oh my god!
That's like OG!
Who the fuck is he?
Ah fuck.
I'm dead.
Doesn't matter I'm dead.
Please cover me.
Please I'm just a harmless Pathfinder.
Okay.
I'm okay.
He's not even a Dragoon cause he literally said from four years ago!
That's when you're like super... Oh fuck.
That's when you know you're super OG.
I swear to god.
Okay.
Are you please...
Please stop.
I haven't shot my gun.
Please.
Man I wish I can regen and smoke.
Alright.
I need HP though.
Oh my god I have no scope for this.
Please.
Please I'm begging you.
Give me anything.
Alright we gotta help Niko.
Niko we're coming over.
Don't worry.
Where is he?
Oh my god, I cannot... this fucking scope sucks.
I forgot how fucking shitty it is.
So... do iron sight path... I'm gonna thirst him.
Iron sight fucking flatline is so hard.
I don't want to grapple because I can see there's a pathfinder on the right.
Fuck it.
What's gonna happen?
Me dying?
Oh shit!
Okay, it's fine.
That's fine.
Oh, that's fine.
Please thirst him.
For the sake of my HP.
Oh, why did you thirst him?
No, I wanted an armor swap!
No!
Why?
I wanted a fucking armor swap.
Please!
Please, they're coming!
No!
Okay.
There's no way he knows I'm here healing.
There's no fucking way.
They'll kill my teammates first before they kill me and that's okay.
That's the risk I'm willing to take.
Oh, thank god.
There's like actual... there's a fucking scope now.
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, let's see.
What can I do?
Take 25% less damage.
Grapple cooldown.
I mean, that seems like the only good thing from pathfinder.
Haha.
That seems like... the other one sucks.
When will I ever need to use my Ziff and like not take damage?
Alright.
Nice.
Oh hey, he is.
That's what I like to see.
Who the fuck is Nico?
I like how he never even told me who he is.
I'm just like, who?
Who are you?
Have I played with this guy before?
Great.
All ready.
A sacrifice I'm... exactly.
As long as the streamer is alive.
They get to, you know...
Little Niko there gets a little bit of the... the high life, you know?
They need me alive.
They need the streamer cam.
Oh my god, it's THE Niko.
You guys don't even know who he is.
The only reason why you're cheering for him...
...is because...
Does he like recognize me?
So you can self-insert yourself in him.
Where the fuck are people?
Oh my god, there's five squads left?
Like how he's never... did he say anything?
He hasn't even... he's never responded!
There's nobody here.
I feel like we have to go to the zone and... oh wait.
No!
That's an Eva 8?
Really?
Come on guys, we gotta go.
But I don't want to be the first one over.
Oh.
Wait, what?
Huh?
Oh, it's over there.
Alright.
Let's go.
No!
I couldn't get the Eva 8.
Alright.
Where the fuck are they?
Oh shit, there they are.
I feel like I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die from this.
Nico, go in.
Die for me.
Die for Joe Keeberg from four years ago.
Wait, where are they?
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh.
I mean, okay.
There's no way he went for me!
What?
That's fucking crazy!
I was like, you're gonna peek that still?
I did not expect him to come back.
I didn't expect that.
I thought he would, you know... I thought after your one HP, you know, you're like, maybe I should heal.
I can't believe he came back for me.
It's okay.
We have Nico.
From four years ago.
Nico collab!
I wonder if Nico's like on my fucking friends list.
I like played...
Whoa!
Oh shit!
Nico!
Thank you.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh my god, it's the fireball.
The fireball is scary.
Oh shit, Nico did it.
Oh my god, Nico!
He... what?
He killed everybody.
I like added so many people on this account as long as they're fucking cracked.
I was like, yes.
Nico's got me.
Oh my god, Nico!
Nico!
Thank you.
Nico's got me again.
Oh my god, I can win by doing absolutely nothing.
Watch this.
Nico, go!
He's like a Pokemon.
Go, Nico!
Oh shit, maybe I should help Nico though.
Hello.
Oh my god, whoops!
Whoa!
Wait, there's a teammate right here that's helping me.
Guys, he's so low, I swear to god!
No!
Shoot him!
He's literally right there!
It's so easy to shoot!
What the fuck is loot dispenser?
Okay, bye.
No!
Loot dispenser, help him!
Guys, I think... I don't think Nico's gonna get this.
Wait, unless...
No!
They're so close!
Okay, that was my fault.
I fucking aggroed so hard.
I was like...
I was...
I'm sorry.
I got a little bit too excited.
I forgot I was supposed to not do anything.
That was...
That was my bad.
I was like, oh yeah.
I was like, wait, maybe I can shoot my gun.
And...
And that was my bad.
I forgot.
I forgot I was supposed to let other people shoot for me.
Oh my god.
But also, what the fuck was loot dispenser doing?
Where was he?
How could this happen to Nico from four years ago?
Okay, let me...
Actually, I'm curious.
Do I actually have Nico on my friends list?
Let's see.
Okay, Nico.
No, I do not.
All right.
Okay.
I don't know who the fuck Nico is.
But I...
I have...
I've noted who Nico is, but he is not in my friends list.
All right.
At least...
At least that I know.
Who the fuck is he?
Apparently, he's from four years ago.
But who?
Truly a mystery.
I can't add him.
It doesn't show.
He has the thing where he doesn't want randoms to add him.
He doesn't want like chitters like me to add him.
What is he?
He's in this guy's...
All right.
Sorry, I didn't...
My audio check guy was like, hey, you can turn down your game volume a little bit.
All right.
This is the last game we're going to invite Gumio over to play.
I just wanted to explore.
Manio?
Oh my God, Rafe.
He's alleged...
He's Nico from four years...
He's...
He appears once every four years.
I'll never see him again.
The only time we can ever see Nico from four years ago...
is to wait another four years.
We will never forget you, Nico.
Until we meet again in four years.
Until we mark this calendar.
2028.
Whatever date it is today.
We will meet Nico again.
Best if he's Nico from GTA.
Alright, here we go.
Oh shit, TikTok.
Okay guys, I'll tell you guys...
I was gonna like...
save... I was gonna reveal it later.
But you guys know how I got a play button?
So like, apparently you could put...
any name.
on there.
You can put any name on the play button.
So I put...
Doki Bird...
FPS V2.
But it's...
Fuck.
You can put any...
Oh shit!
Okay.
Please!
Leave me!
Oh my...
I swear to God.
Give me one gun.
I swear...
I swear to God.
I just want one gun.
Okay.
Gun?
Oh, thank God.
Nice.
Okay, I got a gun.
Oh my God.
Mario!
Where?
Oh my God.
Holy shit.
Castrape.
Woo!
Oh, they're everywhere!
They're everywhere!
Alright.
I didn't realize there were three people there.
Alright, anyway.
Sorry.
That was...
That was unlucky.
Look, if I had a gun...
Okay, Goomy, one more game.
One more game, Goomy.
One more game.
Look, it's because we had Mario.
Alright.
Oh, hey, it's this TikTok guy!
It's TikTok guy again.
Look, it's because, like, I just didn't have a gun.
What can I say?
Is he that...
I don't know.
It's actually OP.
What the fuck does Seer have?
Increased Passive...
Faster Movement...
Wait, I wanna know.
Increased Throw Range...
Increased Tactical Scan...
I mean, that's alright.
Is it really that OP?
Wait, is that Niko?
No, okay.
God damn it.
I thought you guys actually baited me.
I was like, did I actually forgot how to read and missed out on Niko?
Oh my God.
Happy Tree.
He has a TSM banner and he has a 4K Damage Badge.
Oh my God.
God, I hope he's controller too.
To be fair, they, like, nerfed controller players hard by taking up all... taking all the configs out.
Thank fucking God.
The moment they banned all configs, like, it was, like, so noticeable when, like, games suddenly got, like, incredibly easier because, like, all the controller players didn't have movement anymore.
It actually got so much easier.
Much easier to play.
Thank fucking God.
It's crazy though.
See in that video about all the configs people can use on Roller?
It's actually crazy.
Where's Niko?
He's dead!
Oh fuck.
Okay, there's a gun.
Did Doki get a gun?
I did!
Nice.
Doki got a gun.
Whoa!
Again already?
What?
Where are they?
He got shot at but where?
Where?
I swear to...
Everybody is everywhere!
Everywhere but near me.
Oh, there!
I heard like...
I heard a watch that's near me.
So I'm gonna slowly heal up in my smoke.
Yay, self-heal!
Where?
Oh, Seer, please!
Seer!
It's fine.
We're fine.
We got help!
We gotta help him!
Nice.
I'm gonna take that armor swap real fast.
Oh no!
I swear to god, I'm forever lost in this area.
Oh, new team?
Woo!
New team.
Let me block this real fast.
No, Happy Tree!
Don't worry, I got you!
There's no Waze coming over!
There's literally a nade!
It's okay.
Please, Seer, come closer.
Seer!
Crawl to me!
Okay, it's fine.
I didn't need you to crawl to me anyway.
Woo!
Okay.
Alright.
How the fuck did he have... Woo!
Are you serious?
How did he have all...
I didn't have all!
Oh my god.
Alright.
Wait, he was... Oh yeah, cause he had all.
I was gonna be like, what?
I didn't even get his arm?
I didn't even get his HP?
Alright.
Okay.
Now.
Now we can do it.
Alright, let me call Goomy.
Let me call Goomy.
Shit, Nico!
Shit, okay, who the f...
Hey.
Why are you screaming?
Cause I got... I got... I got Nico from four years ago joining us.
What the fuck, CookieBurn?
I don't know who he is.
Dude.
I just kept hearing you say, who the fuck is this dude?
But I'm playing CookieBurn on the side.
He's like the legend!
He's the legend, Nico!
Alright, invite me and I'll invite Nico.
I think he'll...
I'm not here making shit up, I'll be honest.
No, no, I swear to God.
Okay, okay, where is he?
I'm pretty sure he'll ditch his game for us.
I'm pretty sure.
Wait, where the fuck is he?
He's not even in my...
Wait, did he log off?
He doesn't exist.
He's not real.
I swear!
Get out of here.
I swear to God I... There he is, Nico!
Okay, alright, alright.
Alright, I'm gonna see if he'll ditch his game for us.
Alright.
I think he'll ditch.
I invited him.
If he's like a true... a true homie, he'll ditch his game for us.
Oh my God!
Where the fuck is he?
Wait, who are you?
From 4E.
Who is this guy?
Bro, but he's crack though.
Who are you?
Nico from 4E?
We played in season 3.
Oh shit.
Nico from 4 years ago.
He's making shit up.
He's like, yeah, I went to your high school.
Bro, no!
Okay.
Oh shit, I started... whoops, I forgot.
Sounds fun.
No, Doders, no way.
Oh, wait, I accidentally toggled.
I'm sorry, I can't stop my emotions right now.
You toggled what?
I can't stop my emotions.
I'm trying to reset my emotions right now.
Oh!
What was this?
Oh, okay, I got it.
Sorry.
I don't want to be Choke Master.
It's okay, Nico.
Nico will be... God damn it!
This is why we invited you, Nico!
No!
Nico!
Jump or kick.
That's what we thought, Nico.
Yeah, that's what we thought, bitch!
Jump or kick.
Oh my god, bro.
Okay, to be fair, I played with a lot of people.
I don't know, these are the first seasons of...
What's going on?
I'm okay, I'm okay.
Goofy!
Goofy, stop!
Just die!
So I can press you.
There we go, Nico got you.
I literally got you!
Okay, that's not my fault.
Nico got, or literally killed him for us.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Alright.
Sorry, Nico's got us.
I literally have one gun.
There's more people, there's more people.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
It's fine.
It's not fine!
I cracked him, I literally cracked him, please!
Nico, no!
Nico!
Clutch your kick!
Oh my god, he has an arrow in him!
I don't have one of those!
Oh my god, he can talk!
He's not just a fucking Apex bot, he actually can speak!
He can actually talk!
He's kind of moving like a Fortnite bot right now.
I like it.
Okay, I think he has to be mousing keyboard.
I remember...
Because I only play with MNK players in season 3.
Because controller players never existed back then.
Oh!
Go Nico, go!
Oh my god, he grabbed me!
Leave!
Just leave!
Nico, run!
Put your heirloom away, man!
Look, he earned that fair and square, Gumi.
He...
Oh my god, Nico!
It's okay, he's fine.
It's Nico time.
This is really cool.
You know what?
It's a good thing we died.
Now we can actually watch real gameplay.
Yeah, now I'm opening up MNK again.
Now this is like actual real gameplay.
Someone that can actually play Apex.
I don't know when was the last time I played.
Thanks for the... Oh my god, he's got the brain!
Thanks for the free...
Thanks for the free entertainment, Nico!
Oh my god, nice.
Nico POV.
I swear to god, I bet my chat's like, I hope you...
I hope you...
I hope you die again in-game so...
you can watch Nico.
So we can...
I swear they still only have...
like, whoa!
I'm scared!
I'm scared, Doki!
I'm so scared!
I'm fucked.
Nico, I cracked one.
Get up.
Okay, the thing is...
I don't think Nico is getting them.
Doki, there's...
two... there's...
They have literally...
They have purple armor.
It's okay.
I'll be... come back.
I'll come back.
I swear to god.
I'll be... come back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel like I've heard this before.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I swear to god I'll come back.
Don't worry, Yumi.
What are they gonna do?
Like, cap your bodies until you die?
There's no way.
Maybe.
Maybe they will.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
There's no way they'll get that cringe.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Right?
There's no way.
They wouldn't do that to us.
We're streamers.
Right?
Um...
Okay, you guys can't say clutch or kick to me because I'm literally streaming.
Yeah.
Alright.
Are they there?
Who the fuck are you asking?
I don't know!
You guys might have better eyes than me!
I'm looking from your eyes!
Yeah, but you guys might look better.
Oh, nice.
Okay, there you go.
See, I told you guys.
I told you.
Alright, I do have better eyes than you.
I said, oh, don't fear you!
What?
Ah!
Okay, okay, it's fine.
Oh, I accidentally...
There we go.
Alright, it's fine.
We're fine.
It's fine.
I don't know why the fuck the crypto was there.
Yeah.
That was...
Alright, it's fine.
We're fine.
Hey, what is that little yellow...
I have... Oh!
It's an armor upgrade.
I swear to god I heard the fucking crypto again!
Oh, me?
I'm alone!
Holy shit!
What is the piece that could be crushed then?
Oh my god, I dead slid.
I dead slid.
I slid myself.
I panicked.
Okay, that was...
Ice creamer!
Shut the fuck up!
I'm panicking!
I'm literally panicking!
I didn't get enough sleep to be doing this.
My fire...
My water...
Shut the fuck up!
Is my...
Air...
Oh, they're fighting!
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Alright.
It's like they're so confused at me nading myself that they just...
They stop chasing me.
Am I singing calm me down?
I know.
Yeah.
We'll say that.
Yeah, yeah.
Beautiful singing, Gumi.
Beautiful singing.
Alright, don't worry.
We're fine.
Oh, yeah.
See?
I calmed down.
Look at that.
I just needed a rest, you guys.
And it's just like nothing bad happened.
Everything's fine.
What did they do to the train yard?
Boy, it looks the same.
That's literally what it looked like last season.
No.
What happened to the flo- Everything's different.
It's just literally...
This looks different.
They made it purple.
Looks the same.
Oh, we're in a floating train car.
Okay, okay, Gumi.
You haven't played Apex in a while.
Dude, I feel like a boomer.
I feel it.
You literally haven't played Apex in so long.
It's literally the same train yard.
That's funny.
This would cost 25 cents.
Oh, I need to make my bat.
Oh, yeah.
You can only use replicator like once now.
What?
Yeah.
We're all okay.
I'm still with the shittiest guns possible right now with zero attachments.
And that's okay.
Nice.
I upgraded.
What?
Don't worry.
I upgraded our shit.
Oh, nice.
There's like fights near us on the other side.
There's not a vault here.
No, I'm good.
I'm good.
It's okay.
We have Niko.
I bet you Niko's gonna get our first win today.
Really?
Oh, shit.
Niko might be dead.
Niko!
Wake up, Niko!
Wake up, samurai.
That's my ult.
I'm gonna hurt myself.
Help me, Niko!
It's my ult.
You're fine.
I hit nothing.
That's cool.
Go me!
Go me?
What's going on?
Where are they?
Can you ping it?
I don't see nothing.
I'm in a few, salty.
Where are they?
Oh!
Splash!
Got him!
Got Nicholas!
His teammates over there.
Yeah, I got him.
Cracked him.
He's plush.
Stupid.
Nice.
Yeah!
Look at us go.
We're gaming.
We're so much better.
Look at that.
Are you okay?
Let me look at sound check guys and see if you're not bursting people's eardrums.
Okay, he's like, everything is good.
Go me!
Stop!
Stop getting shot at!
Go me!
I'm okay.
Oh my god, I hit nothing.
That's awkward.
I didn't hit a single thing.
Where are you?
Nico, no!
How are we gonna win?
Oh, they're coming!
Oh, I can't see.
I can't see for you.
I can't cover you.
Wait, they have red armor.
Wait, they're gamers.
Wait, we lost our actual carry.
What the fuck do we do?
By the way, they're...
I don't have red armor!
I died, Goomy.
I can't help you.
Oh, you're dead too.
Monkey?
Wait, you're still alive!
I thought you were dead.
Oh my god!
Are you okay?
Why didn't you...
Why didn't you Q-inter?
They went up my ass!
You could have ran!
I abandoned you!
What do you mean I abandoned you?
What?
You were not funny.
Yes, you could have done that!
You could have... I abandoned you!
I abandoned you and came back!
That's okay.
No.
We all know it's Nico's fault.
Yeah, fuck you Nico.
How dare you.
Why are you in our three stack if you're not clutch?
If you're not clutching.
Wait!
We're three stacking!
We should play rank!
We're all...
We could be farming the bronze players!
The real bronze...
It's like...
Okay, look.
Okay, hear me out.
The game came out...
The new season patch came out like...
11, 12, 1, 2... 4 hours ago.
Preds shouldn't be in Rookie anymore at that point.
They should have ranked out of it.
I have people from DSG and they're ranking up right now, surely.
Which means all the Preds are playing right now, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're all playing.
But they've been playing for 4 hours.
If they play for 4 hours...
What if they keep inting each other and they're all still bronze?
There's no way!
Then they're dogshit!
Oh!
Okay, I didn't say it.
All I'm saying is...
If they're still in bronze...
Not even bronze.
They start off at Rookie.
We start at Rookie because everyone starts at one point.
Look.
I'm saying if in 4 hours...
You're still in Rookie.
And you're...
You're a professional player that gets paid to play Apex Legends...
It's not an us problem.
It's a you problem.
It's okay, we have Niko.
Niko, if you hand that shit over...
What the fuck, Niko?
Don't worry, we say one thing.
Clutch or jump.
Oh, wait, wait.
Kick or jump.
There you go.
Oh my... Niko!
Jump or kick.
That's not it.
Alright,
here we go.
Isn't it great?
Isn't it great when we have a carry?
I see people here with us, Doki.
It's okay, we have a carry.
It's some guy...
used to play in Season 3.
Doki, they're gonna beat his ass!
They're beating his ass!
It's okay!
As long as it's not us, it's okay.
Oh shit, maybe we should help him.
Coming over!
Oh shit, Niko, no!
Oh, he's got him.
Niko, don't die, cause I need ammo.
Don't die, cause I...
Damn.
Where's the third?
Where the fuck is the third player?
There's fuckers!
Oh shit!
Oh, go away!
What happened?
It's the... it's the fucker!
Where?
Oh, I'll raise you.
Don't worry, Niko's got this.
See?
We killed the TTV-er!
And New York!
There's a new team.
Blocking this.
Ow!
Oh, I can't see anything.
Nice.
There's a teammate.
Where's your craft?
Where?
Oh shit, here!
Okay.
Easy.
So easy.
Oh, it's like the new armor swap.
But instead of swapping the armor, it just fills up your armor.
Oh.
Oh hey, we killed everybody here!
See?
What were you worried about?
Yeah, I have 2 KP.
I'm a big kid now.
Yeah, but what's your damage?
Huh?
600.
Oh yeah, I have 7...
Oh shit.
I have 705.
What the?
Yeah.
Now you're making shit up.
What, me?
No.
Wait, wait, wait.
Sorry.
Sorry, verbal typo.
I mean...
Sorry, I had a mini stroke right now.
I'm at 130.
Oh.
Oh hey, everyone makes shit up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Whoa!
Gold backpack!
Oh.
I thought I was like wondering what he's shooting at.
Uh...
Alright, let me...
Get rid of my battery.
Whoa!
Oh, I heard like...
I heard the...
Oh my god, Nico, are you getting fucked in HD?
52.
Is the 2 team a 2?
I think it's 3.
I cracked the seer though.
I only saw 2 with my little passive.
Cracked the seer again?
Alright, do it.
Come on, go, go, go, go, go, go!
I believe in you, Gumi!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Whoa!
I sure hope my teammates are here with me!
I sure hope so too!
Wait, where's the seer?
Oh, on me.
Hello!
Nice.
I feel like it's so cluttered though.
Like all the...
the words on my screen.
Yeah, I don't know how to read.
Senior by ordinance.
I don't need names.
It just feels so cluttered.
Is Nico single?
Alright, who wants to be the...
You don't even know how old he is, man!
Hold on!
First off, we gotta ask how old Nico is!
First off!
What is that?
Before we ask if anybody is single, we need to know how old Nico is!
We need to know how old Nico is!
Remember, the order of the questions matter!
Guys!
The order of the questions!
Guys, I know Valentine's is tomorrow, but remember!
The order of questions!
The order of operations!
At least four!
The truth!
Nico, the fucking child prodigy!
Playing Apex in the fucking womb!
Oh my god!
He's like that ten year old Apex Pred player or some shit.
You know, there's like...
What's his name?
What?
There's like this controller prodigy Pred player.
Who's like this ten year old kid.
And his like...
His dad runs his like...
Oh, there's people on us, I think.
His dad runs his like Twitch and everything.
And all he does is just play Apex while his dad controls his...
Whoa!
You go!
Go!
Go where?
Here!
See?
Oh, we gotta help Nico.
Wait, they're rezzing!
Where is he?
Oh shit!
Oh, this is dead.
I helped.
Yeah, you were there.
What?
I threw mage, man.
Yeah, you were there.
Yeah, I was there.
Sometimes I wonder if you're okay.
How the fuck he answer?
Alright.
Oh, I can heal myself in smoke.
Oh my god, we're gonna get our first win!
I believe in us.
Don't say that!
We're gonna get our first win!
Wait, did I grab my shield back?
Oh my god, it cramps right away!
Yeah, that's the new update.
But you only craft once.
YOLO.
Luvisa's as insane as ever.
That's why she's my friend.
Yeah.
I need someone to make me feel normal.
What?
LOL.
Hey, next to you, most normal person.
I heard something.
It's okay.
Oh, Narnia.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, so if we don't look at them, they don't exist.
Right?
Ken only has a good day
Whoa, Nico's just a Ken?
That's fucked up.
He can be a Barbie if he wants.
Not if he keeps relinquishing Jump Master.
Ooh, that's true.
Nico, do something!
Go!
Kill everyone!
Go, Goomy!
I see a motherfucker stay up right there!
Yeah, they're over here.
Whoa, shit!
Okay, I almost fell.
Oh, righta, righta, righta!
How do I climb back up?
There you go.
Go, Goomy, go.
Oh wait, no, he's all the way up there.
Bastard!
Oh wait, they changed this a little bit.
Whoa!
Knocked one.
Oh, right here.
Oh, cracked him.
Oh, he's grappling away.
Oh my god, that poor guy.
I just saw him get executed.
Where the fuck is this Pathfinder though?
Above?
He's above me?
Oh, oh!
Oh my god, he scared the shit out of me.
He's like above me?
There's people behind me.
It's fine.
Whoa.
Not fine, not fine.
Whoa, where are you?
Um, there's a guy right here where I'm pinging.
What the fuck was he doing?
Why did he crouch there?
Another team is fighting in front of us.
There's a new team.
My Oshiniko is not single.
I'm day ruined.
No.
Oh, I got a heal now.
It's okay, I have self heal.
I'm leading.
Oh shit.
Oh, I'm knocked.
But I knocked one too.
Uh oh.
Uh oh, uh oh.
I'm shielding, I'm shielding.
Uh oh.
Uh oh, uh oh.
Oh, they tried it!
We got... No, we were so close!
Oh my god, what is this?
Nico, you ruined all of our days.
No, we just didn't three stack hard enough.
We did not three stack hard enough.
I knocked mine.
We...
Alright, mate, don't worry.
We'll get first place in rank.
Boot us up.
Lock us in.
Okay.
Do it.
Wait, is he rookie as well?
Okay, thank god.
Lock us in.
Alright, is Karnu still strong in rank?
I don't know what's meta.
I don't know what's meta either.
I just like Venti.
Yeah, I know.
Okay, okay.
I know.
It's okay.
All the Preds... All the Preds ranked out are rookie.
There's no way.
There's no way we're that unlucky.
We're gonna be the ones that that like bone rush all the players.
Yes.
Karnu got nerfed?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I guess I'll play Bangalore.
Apparently Karnu is nerfed.
Wait, okay.
How about Seer?
I know how to play Seer.
Actually, no.
I should play Bangalore.
That's my comfort pick.
No, there's no way.
They had four hours.
If they can't get a...
out of rookie in four hours, then why the fuck are they Pred?
Yeah.
Just think about it.
It literally takes like five games to get a rookie if you're in Pred.
If you're a Pred player.
All right, Niko.
Take us home.
Niko?
Niko, come on.
Haha, I rejoined at the right?
We're dropping Among Us.
Don't worry, I believe in us.
You played Among Us?
You were an Among Us player.
Where's your professional?
You were in all those streamer lobbies.
Yeah, that's right.
That's Miss Gumiho, the Among Us player.
Yeah.
Yeah, she was in all those Among Us lobbies.
Yeah, I know her.
Oh, triple take!
Yeah.
She was like...
Yeah, I know her.
She was like in the...
Disguised Toast lobbies.
She was a pretty big deal.
Oh, hello, Sia.
Rookie!
Wait, were you actually in the Toast lobbies though?
No, man.
I was in the Hafu lobbies.
Oh, you're in the Hafu lobbies.
Yeah, she was in the Hafu lobbies.
She's a pretty big deal.
Knocked one.
Where's his teammate though?
Teammates?
Oh, shit.
I told you!
Look, they're all rookies!
Because they all start rookies.
Hey, purple backpack here.
Oh, nice.
Better take it before Nico does.
Oh, pinged it.
He respects pings, right?
Where's their third though?
Oh, no.
Oh, fuck.
They don't have a third player?
Apparently they do.
Did they run already?
Already?
Please, I have zero kills.
I don't wanna be joining.
Hello?
I guess he ran off.
Okay, okay.
Oh, wait, I heard someone.
Where?
No!
I couldn't farm.
You should like let me tap it.
Well, that wasn't me who did that.
Fucking Nico.
We should kick him out.
Yeah.
I think so too.
Hahaha.
Lesson number one.
Always let us tap.
Hold on, don't say it like that.
Hahaha.
Hold on.
Wait a minute.
I didn't sign up for this.
I...
Okay, Nico.
IGLS.
IGLS, Nico.
Tell us what to do.
Wait.
He's leaving.
Wait, Digi doesn't go to R9 anymore?
It goes to shotgun and...
What?
I didn't know that.
You don't use Digi on R9...
on like...
R9 anymore.
What the fuck did that happen?
Non-SMGs.
Wow!
A bow!
Nico, don't call yourself the Mama Duck ever again.
Yeah.
That's cringe.
That's pretty fucking cringe.
Hahaha.
That's fucking cringe, man.
I'm cringing right now.
I'm cringing.
God, typically PxClare.
Wait, where?
I used it in no direction, Nico.
I wish we could melee boost.
I missed that.
Oh shit.
You just punched the shit out of me.
What?
I mean, if you consented...
Um...
Hahaha.
I mean, that's what you're into.
Oh!
Remember, you have white armor.
Hahaha.
Woah!
Um...
Wait, there's another team over there.
Uh?
I'm busy.
Wait, I'm scaled now.
They're all white armor.
I'm gonna ult this.
Am I ult?
They're like, up on the rock.
Cracked him?
One on here.
All dead?
Nice.
Alright, I'm just pushing up then.
Oh shit, look at all these boxes.
Nice.
I'm gonna grab this real fast.
Will you guys be okay?
I'm looting, I'm looting.
This is important.
What?
This is more important than...
Oh shit, Nico!
Okay, I'm coming over.
Alright, don't worry.
I should...
Level up myself.
Nico, if you don't get him!
Why I... Why I oughta...
There you go.
Is there anything, buddy?
Is there people in front of us?
Cause I'm looting, I'm looting.
No.
Nice.
Nico!
Are you not res?
What is going on?
What's going on?
Nothing.
Nice.
Look at that.
I contributed.
I'm gonna push forward.
And see if there's people in front of us.
Oh!
There was a Loba ult up there.
Did they use it?
Wait, they did.
They should come down to us.
Okay, let's just wait.
Yeah, they're here.
Come on, Loba!
Oh my god, that poor guy.
Where's his teammate?
Where's your teammate, Loba?
It's a team of two.
White armor and blue armor.
Tracked him?
There.
Good for 50?
Nice.
Aww.
Hello, rookie.
I wanna stay in this elo forever.
Isn't that great?
Here we go.
Don't even have a redeploy.
I have a... I hear fighting north side.
North side?
Okay, I'm going over.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Wait, someone has a Kraber.
Yeah, they're fighting hard.
They're fighting hard.
On me?
What?
Down?
Left side?
Oh, careful of the fucking...
ball of fire.
Wait, what?
Oh, nice.
Flash?
I'm worried.
I think they're gonna rez my kill.
Pushing up.
Hit 53.
Flash?
In front of me?
I'm pushing.
There's an ult in front of me, so I can't push.
Careful, Goomy.
You're by yourself.
Yeah, I'm killing.
Flash?
They have a bow check or something.
They're fine.
They're dead.
Off the river.
There's him.
Nice.
Where's the...
Oh, Niko.
Dead.
Okay, there was another team over there earlier.
Yeah, I think they rez my kill.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure they rez'd it.
Let's see.
Oh, I can regen on my heals now.
Yippee!
And loot.
I love loot.
Oh, in front of me?
In front of me?
And they're fighting to my left.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right here?
I'm pushing.
I'm medding.
Oh my god.
Oh, he's one.
I fucked up my aim there.
There's a guy behind this box.
That's low.
Or he healed.
There's a guy right behind this too.
Oh, nice.
They got the kill.
There's a team with blue armor.
Yeah, it's just a Seer.
There's a team on my right as well.
We should be fine.
Yeah.
I think we have to go to zone soon though.
You know what?
Fuck you.
Are they rez'ing?
Alright, I'm finishing.
Nice.
I made a statement.
I think there's like people in front of me though.
I'm right behind you.
Yeah, there's a rez.
Rez in front.
Woah!
I'm ulting.
Pushing this.
This is like non-stop fighting.
I love this elo.
I'm gonna ult myself.
Can't push anymore.
Yeah, I saw that.
Shut it, but I forgot.
Look, I forgot.
They just ran.
Look, they're just running away.
Not fair.
Do we have redeploy?
Redeploy.
I spelled redeploy wrong.
Now!
Where's our redeploy?
Nico, you literally have redeploy!
Oh my god.
God damn it, Nico.
Okay.
We need to go to zone though.
Yeah, they went up.
Yeah, they have high ground.
I'm pushing up.
Nico, it's all your fault.
This is all your fault.
I said redeploy.
I said one simple word.
You didn't say that.
I heard it.
Yeah, I heard it too.
We all heard it.
Yep, we all heard it.
I'm gonna take the Bonsai platform.
Deploy or kick.
Oh, there he is.
There's his teammate though.
What's your real rank?
Mr. Mr. Loba.
Can I farm you?
Let's see.
Go Nico.
Tell us what their rank is if they can shoot you.
Won't know if they can aim.
I'm gonna go to the right.
Knocked?
What the fuck are they doing?
Flush?
Oh.
He's dead.
Goodbye!
There he is.
He's gone.
It's fine.
That is not my ult, by the way.
That could be a different team's ult.
I need ammo.
No land energy?
Fuck.
Where's the other guy we killed?
I can drop you 16 energy right here.
Yeah, I need it.
There's a new team.
In front of us.
Now you're not fighting.
Yeah, we're literally right in front.
Hard fighting?
Oh!
40?
Sorry, I don't know if it's 40.
I made up the number.
Okay.
Oh, look at him go!
Flush?
I'm just gonna...
Yeah, I'm gonna fucking head to zone.
Oh, hey!
What's that?
Ah!
You didn't get it?
No.
Alright, I'll take it.
I was running out anyway.
I was running out of ammo.
Might as well.
Wait, what?
He needed us.
Who is it?
Oh!
There was an Urskan.
Uh.
Was it you or Niko that punched me?
Look where I am.
Like, what do you think?
I'm so far from you.
We need to go to zone though.
I don't know.
Alright, I'm heading down.
Super in zone!
Super Niko.
Let Niko... No!
If he was a real gamer, he would have a fucking bottle.
That's called the streamer life.
What do you mean great about...
Next merch idea.
The gamer bottle.
Eww.
Where the fuck are...
There's still like three teams left.
Where are they?
Yeah, go for it.
Really?
What do you mean no?
If he was a real gamer, he'd hold it in.
Or get a bottle.
Only real gamers know.
Oh, wait there's two next to us.
There's two above us.
They just rest.
Where the fuck is the...
No, there's two like right next to us somewhere.
Wait, that's a...
There's one right above me.
Are they like...
Up top?
Oh, yeah!
Tracking?
Okay.
Last guy.
He's like literally one guy.
Oh, army?
Cracked him?
Cracked the bloodhound?
In front of us?
Cracked him?
Not?
He's cracked.
Okay, but I'm not letting this guy res though.
Cracked?
Okay, I'm gonna go back.
Is this the last guy?
Yeah!
I told you!
I told you rank is so easy to farm.
It's easier to farm than fucking pause.
I told you so easy.
What the fuck?
Oh, god!
Now what happened?
My screen.
Oh, yeah.
Nice.
Turns out the triple wasn't that epic.
Oh, yeah.
The triple take is nerfed as hell.
Dude, they just don't want me to play this game.
Oh, my god.
How many points did we gain there?
425.
I told you!
It literally takes like 4-5 games for a player to get out a rookie.
For literally rookie 3.
Oh, my god.
It was a legendary frame.
It literally took us like one game to get to rookie... almost to rookie 2.
Please, I wanna stay in rookie forever.
Please, it's so fun.
It's like OG.
OG pubs.
It's okay.
He can like speedrun.
He's a man.
It's alright.
Look at that!
Gumi, we did it!
We won!
Are you proud of us?
Yeah, I'm proud.
We did it!
Yay!
Yippee!
Are you gonna let Nico join the voice chat?
Girls only!
No men allowed!
Yeah!
My game crashed.
Oh, my god.
Guys, I don't think my game...
My only thing my game likes is that I restricted the voice chat.
Let me put my game back up.
It's okay.
I'm coming back.
I'm coming.
Nico is literally not dropping us.
I think he also crashed.
No, he's using the bathroom right now.
He's using...
Dude, I can't leave or else it...
I'm back!
Really?
The game was like, rise up, men.
Men, don't let her talk about us like this.
There's someone!
It's okay.
Just kill him.
What are you afraid of?
Oh!
Gumi, Gumi, what happened?
Gumi, what happened?
What do you mean?
I think these guys are gamers now.
They're not regular rookies.
They're not regular rookie players.
Oh, I don't have frames right now.
Woo!
There's another team.
That's why we don't let Nico.
This is Nico's fault.
Yeah.
I blame Nico.
Yeah, Nico just got owned.
What's wrong with you, Nico?
Yeah, what's wrong with you?
Anyways.
What's wrong with you, Nico?
This is your fault.
Oh, he has teammates?!
You know, if I had teammates, I wouldn't have died.
My rookie boys!
I'm good.
I'm good now.
Okay.
Look, we blame Nico, right?
Yeah.
He doesn't have a voice, so we can blame him.
No, there's no MMR!
We just landed somewhere.
That had actual good players.
Oh, we're on trios.
Wait, were we not in rank?
Were we?
No, we were.
No!
Gooby!
Gooby, take us back!
Take us back to rank!
It was so much more fun!
My bad.
I went to go get a shumai.
Oh, nice.
How is it?
It's cold.
Nice.
Not nice.
Just as for Nico.
Let him speak.
Dude, I don't wanna hear it.
If he wanted to talk to us, he could have used the open VC in the game.
Right?
What's stopping him from using that?
Exactly.
Yeah.
Honestly, even if Nico were here, do you think he could talk over us?
Do you hear us?
True.
I don't even hear my own thoughts.
Let Nico speak.
This Goomyho, the real Goomyho.
Yes, the among us Minecraft Goomyho.
And Valorant.
Can we change how you introduce me?
Oh, sorry.
The Minecrafter.
Is that...
My game crashed.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I guess we gotta swap to Mel right now.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Give me a sec.
I'm coming back.
I'm coming back right now.
Give me a sec.
Okay, here we go.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright, for some reason it's windowed now.
That's not great.
I don't know why I keep crashing.
See, Fae?
Every Apex update fucks up the PC.
One way or another.
Okay, just don't let me die.
Please.
Nico's landing is just one spot away.
Okay.
Let me make sure we're not windowed.
Alright, I'm good.
I'm gonna have shit frames for one second.
Uhhh...
We don't have people contesting us.
No.
No, they're far.
Okay.
Want that?
Shitty gun.
She's special to me!
Yeah, but it's old and shitty now.
It's like you're talking about me trippin'.
That's why you love the triple take, right?
Hey.
What the fuck?
Hey, you taught me everything I know about looting.
Hey, I can kick you out right now if I want.
Do it.
Oh yeah?
You think I won't?
I'll go take a nap.
Yeah, that's right.
Don't test me.
I'll take Nico away from you right now.
Girl, I don't want him.
What the fuck?
Don't say that in front of chat!
Dude, you shouldn't even ask what his age was!
Is he sad?
What?
You can't blame me on that.
You raised them.
Look, I wouldn't say raised them.
It's more like I gave them an iPad and let them go wild.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, you know, they're iPad kids.
Oh, shit!
Nico!
Okay, okay.
I was not paying attention.
Did he flash?
What?
Hey, I'm getting sniped.
Oh, fuck.
Sorry.
I slid.
That was...
No, no, no, that's fine.
That's fine.
Nico's got this.
Please, Nico, don't die.
Cocomelon!
Give me iPad!
Flash.
It's fine.
We got... Nico's got...
Nico literally 1v2'd.
Let's go.
I literally flashed one and did 50.
Flash it up.
It's fine.
He 1v2'd.
Oh, well.
My loot now.
Nice.
Look, see?
Nothing to worry about.
Oh, that's another squad.
Doki, give me Cocomelon!
What?
Cocomelon!
No, that's gonna damage your brain!
That's gonna damage your cognitive!
Cocomelon!
Don't you know that?
Cocomelon fucks up your cognitive brain!
Also, I got one.
I got rusty loot.
Loot whatever is new.
That's another one.
48.
Flash.
On me?
There's like two teams here.
What the fuck?
I think they like, rez'd.
There's like, still two teams though.
Does anyone have energy?
They raze portal.
Oh, okay.
There's a second team then.
Oh my god, he fucking crazy.
I'm just gonna grab this.
Oh, behind us!
Oh, nice.
Okay.
I couldn't get him.
Wait, he's gonna take the zip?
I think he's gonna get it.
Wait, in front of me?
Bloodhound scan?
Behind?
Right here?
Flash?
I'm shielding.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm bliffing!
It's fine!
Dead, dead, dead, dead!
One more, one more, one more!
New team.
Crap.
Jesus Christ.
How many teams are there?
I'm shielding you, quick.
I need a shield too.
Oh, there's another team behind me!
Please!
I'm going to steal it!
Okay, I'm leaving.
I'm sorry.
I'm gonna heal here.
There's way too many people.
There's people on me.
Yeah, I got shot by all three teams.
That was crazy.
I'm trying to figure out where...
if they're fighting each other now.
Niko's fighting.
Niko, no!
You're crazy!
Don't be a hero!
Niko, no!
Oh my god, he is actually being a hero right now.
Oh, he's dead.
Are you safe?
Are you safe, Niko?
Please speak to me.
I'm okay.
Niko is safe.
No, he's not safe.
You liar!
He was!
You fucking liar!
He literally was!
I don't know what you're talking about.
I can't believe you lied to me like that, Gumi.
Wait.
Rank, rank, rank.
That was definitely not my fault.
Oh my god, he has a voice!
What are you doing?
What are you doing, Niko?
Sorry.
Oh my god, you like whipped him.
What the fuck, boy?
Niko, Niko.
The way he said sorry.
Oh my god.
Niko.
This is your champion.
What do you mean get ready for a crash?
I didn't do anything this time!
That was Gumi!
He will not be silenced.
Oh my god.
I think your chat is down bad.
Alright, Gumi.
Where are we going?
Don't make me say it, Niko.
What the fuck?
That's right.
That's why you haven't been promoted in four years.
Whoa!
You're still only Niko.
Wait, what does that mean?
What does that mean?
What else would he be called?
What would he be called if it wasn't Niko?
There's a guy in the center.
I don't think we should be around here.
There's a guy.
Where the fuck are you?
Like, main?
Like, oh...
Niko and I are underground like, what the fuck?
Alright.
There's a team right here.
I can...
Where are they?
Oh.
Okay.
Where's his teammate?
Oh shit!
Hello.
Will you guys be fine?
Nice.
We're fine.
We might be low health, but that's whatever.
See if I care.
See?
We're okay.
Nothing to worry about.
Niko is best girl.
Wait, then what's Gumi then?
Wait a second.
Come on, guys!
Don't hold yourself.
Hello?
What would Gumi be, guys?
Whoops.
Ramblin' side chick!
Yes!
Gumi the side chick.
Crazy.
Gumi is okay.
Oh.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
You're just okay.
How does that make you feel?
I'm single.
Gumi, I think you're getting a little desperate.
I'm lying!
Yeah?
There's a team over there.
The side character.
Holy fuck.
Gumi, you're getting fucking roasted right now.
You're kidding.
I didn't want that.
There's a team to my right as well.
I don't know if it's two teams or not.
I didn't hear the...
They EMP'd me.
I'm so fucked.
I'm backing up fully.
I don't want to deal with...
I'm going to high ground.
What the fuck?
Niko got a car.
What the?
He's pulling up into whip!
What the fuck is going on?
I'm going to heal real fast though.
I don't know if it's like...
Wait, what?
Why are they crafting?
In the middle of the fight.
One's over here.
Yeah, I'm going to heal real fast.
One's here.
You know what?
Fuck this.
I'm ulting.
Okay.
Oh, they're running.
Wait, what the fuck?
That guy is flesh.
Yeah, that guy to my right.
Oh, another team.
He has white armor though.
This is two teams.
Ooh.
Careful.
I'm killing.
Backing fully.
Because we're surrounded right now.
I'm going to fall back to this building.
Yeah, let's fall back to the roof.
Alright.
Gonna have to slowly crawl up.
You do have to get to the zone kind of soon.
I have a redeploy.
Oh yeah, we gotta go to the zone.
Yeah, we can just redeploy.
We don't have to be here.
I'm going to put it down.
Alright.
Bye guys.
You guys can fight in the zone.
What the fuck do you mean bye guys?
The two teams that are fighting over there?
What the fuck do you mean?
I have abandonment issues!
Don't we... That's why we play Apex.
Where are you going?
I'm taking this redeploy.
We can literally fight them here.
Why did you take another redeploy?
I guess it was.
Oh shit, he's sniping.
Everyone's a fucking critic I guess.
I need like...
Shields if you have any.
They're in the plicky!
I'm gonna throw...
Wait, he's dead.
I'm gonna go for that kill.
Cause I'm gonna rob him.
It's okay, I'm gonna rob this man.
Ew.
Oh shit!
Yes!
Um...
Okay, I did not expect him to have fucking teammates.
Oh, they're on the building!
Wait, they stole our building?
Another notch on the belt.
Okay, we're good.
Why is there on me?
I'm heading over.
I hear a crip- Oh, my game crashed!
No!
Okay, you guys went fine.
Just don't die.
I'm not dying?
What do you mean?
Okay, this is Apex update.
No, please tell me.
Am I still alive?
I'm coming back in!
Oh god, I swear.
This Apex...
What do you mean deserved?
I fucking... I was clutching it!
I saved everybody!
Apex doesn't want me to win.
No!
Let me win!
I was doing too well!
I'm alive.
I...
I was so far!
Goobie, stay alive!
Stay alive for me!
We're all alive.
We literally killed them all.
Oh, nice.
I knew it.
I was there.
What?
I was moral support.
Don't worry.
Stay alive.
I'm coming back.
We're all alive!
Don't worry!
Just don't die!
I swear to god, please don't kick me out for a third time.
Come on.
I'm here!
Don't worry guys!
I'm here now!
And my game is freaking the fuck out!
I'm good.
Nice.
Oh my god.
My game is freaking the fuck out.
Wait, did you guys kill everything?
Woah!
Okay, as long as I don't look down, we're fine.
Oh hey.
Everything's okay.
Everything's okay now.
Wait, what?
Wait, behind me?
Oh, I can't look behind me!
No!
I'm so fucking nerfed right now!
I can't look behind!
They need to fight in front of me!
I...
That's one.
Walk backward!
I can't see!
No!
You guys can't kill him, right?
Don't worry, I'm coming over.
Don't worry, if I walk in the sideways, we'll be fine.
Don't worry.
We killed them.
We killed two of them.
Okay.
I just need to hope that every enemy shoots in front of me.
Then we should be fine.
As long as they're all in front of me.
Oh god.
Oh, this is not great.
Oh, this is not great for me.
This is not...
I don't feel so well.
It's okay.
As long as the enemies are in front of me, and I never look behind me, we'll be fine.
Rhea, this is so...
This simulation is breaking.
Doki, we're going behind you.
Wait, no!
No, you're not supposed to!
I can't function!
Woo!
There's people in front of me.
Let's kill this team.
Easily.
Wait, where did he go?
Was it solo?
Did I freak out over a solo?
I think I freaked out over a solo.
Oh yeah, that's...
That's a rat.
Okay, as long as I'm looking in this general direction, we'll be fine.
What?
Yeah, my textures will be fine.
In front of me?
Oh my god, look at him fucking go.
Splash if you can kill him.
You go kill him, Nico and I are gonna go kill this other team.
He did what you did!
He made him right behind him!
I told you!
It's a good distraction!
There's people on me.
Wait, what?
There's people up there.
I'm back.
It's okay.
It's not zoned though, but...
Wait, I can look again!
I can look!
Fall as well.
Oh my god, I can look behind me.
Here?
Where I'm looking?
Where I'm peeing?
Yeah.
I'm going to the right.
Cause they have to run from zone.
Oh, actually they're going all the way bottom.
Wait, on me?
It's a squad of three.
But where does... whose squad is he from?
Oh no, I can't look behind!
I thought you were all better!
What happened?
I don't know!
I got sick again!
That's how getting sick works!
You don't just magically get better overnight!
Alright, don't worry, I'm okay now.
Nico, no!
No!
I'm dead.
I'm dead!
2-1, 2-1, 2-1!
Dude!
Hey, do you want to reset your game?
Yeah, I'm going to reset my game!
Not being able to look backwards was pretty rough.
Not going to lie.
I'm going to reset that shit real fast.
I can only look one way.
Alright, no, no.
Alright.
We end with another win.
Do you think we do it, Gumi?
Oh?
What'd you say?
We can get a win, right?
Yeah, for sure.
Check drivers?
No!
Because I'm too lazy to restart my PC.
Just want to play video games.
I just want to hang out and play video games.
I invite me.
Yes, ma'am.
That's me.
Oh, we're rookie two.
Come on, we can win.
We need to win.
Plug in roller.
No way you just said that.
I agree though.
What?
GPU is literally dying on stream?
Shh, don't say that.
He's just shy.
My GPU has like performance anxiety.
Don't say that.
The more you judge my GPU, the more it's going to freak out.
The more it's going to freak out.
Yeah, new PC.
Doki.
Yeah?
For Valentine's Day, can you fly both of us to France?
And then we can get a croissant or something.
It's my dog's birthday.
Why don't you fly over?
Yeah!
Why don't you fly over and celebrate my dog's birthday, huh?
You didn't invite me.
I'm inviting you now.
Surprise!
That's...
Oh my god!
You ruined the surprise!
It wasn't going to be a surprise!
A surprise for who?
For me?
Surprise!
You're invited!
You got this GPU, Doki.
I suppose.
Done,
RE.
You're welcome.
Wait, is there people here?
Yep.
Oh shit, I was not paying attention.
Where though?
Are you lying?
They're near me.
They're literally near me.
No.
Okay, actually I believe now.
That guy might be dead.
Can I catch one?
I'm going to help Nico.
Whoa.
Crazy.
Whoa, Nico!
Nice.
Here, here's an armor swap.
There's one, Doki!
No!
I'm coming over.
Oh, you're dead.
Where are they?
Um...
Inside?
I hear someone above me.
Aw, he saw me.
There's someone above me as well.
So, that's what I'm nervous about.
My stomach hurts.
Whoa.
Whoa!
Guess I'll have to fucking...
roll in.
Got you?
That's the person who killed me.
Where's his teammate though?
Um...
I don't know.
I heard his teammate nearby.
Guess not.
It would be a shame if he just shot me just now.
What are you doing?
What is that?
What is what?
For free?
Damn.
Huh?
I...
I got a tiny bit of chippies.
I got some chippies.
Dude, I've been recently drinking this drink.
It's kinda like sody pop, but it's not sody pop.
Where is it?
It has like apple cider vinegar inside of it.
What?
What's it called?
Not sponsored!
Okay.
But what's it called?
It's called poppy.
Poppy?
P-O-P-P-I.
It has apple cider vinegar and it's really good for your gut health.
Are you sure?
Are you sure you're not sponsored?
I'm sure.
I just really like it.
Oh shit, wait.
What's in that package?
I don't know.
That sounds pretty terrible.
Thanks, bruv.
That sounds pretty fucking terrible.
Vinegar and what?
Apple cider vinegar?
You've never had that?
No.
Apple cider... I don't like cider in general, to be honest.
Okay, no.
It's not...
It's not cider, nor is it actually vinegar.
It's like...
It doesn't taste like it.
God, winging.
Wait, what does it taste like?
It just tastes like...
You know those fizzy water drinks with a tiny bit of flavored juice?
Like sparkling water?
Yeah, except like... But like flavored sparkling water.
Yeah, yeah.
Exactly like that.
I was like, no, it's amazing!
Alright, how many poppy sponsors are in here right now?
How many paid bots are on here right now?
In the chat right now?
It's like anytime you mention poppy, all the poppy bots come into the chat.
I was like, yeah, it's so good!
You can buy it here, right here on this Amazon link right now!
Use my referral code!
It's a prebiotic!
It's really good for your skin!
Yeah, I promise!
Anyway, so how many...
Would you like to click on my referral code?
I am!
I'm gonna be shooting!
Yes!
Well, I need to get closer!
Please don't let me die!
NICO!
I'M GONNA KICK YOUR ASS!
What?
What's going on?
I'm fucking shooting them and he's on purpose like, blocking me!
Standing in front of me!
That's my all!
Poppy and bio!
Here, I smoked, but it was 100% not gonna help you.
There's zip lining on your ass!
I cracked him.
That's fucking right, bitch.
What the fuck?
I cracked this guy too?
Cracked an enemy's shield.
Stupid...
Clones.
Up here!
Yeah, there's two that zipped, but his other teammate redeployed.
Got company out there!
Uhh...
I mean, we can...
Do we wanna contest their high ground?
Cause they're just chillin' up there.
NICO's just looting.
I mean, to be fair, it's free loot.
Wait, what the fuck?
Is NICO fighting people?
No, it's them.
Fuses can like...
The fuse can like, chuck names from afar.
Like, from 800 miles.
Dude, that's...
Yeah, that's called fuse.
I'm not that old, man!
You don't have to tell me!
You just talked to me like I'm...
I can't do something!
They're running?
Oh shit, NICO's going in!
He's going in!
I just realized you're still white armor.
Yeah.
Go help him!
Wait, where are they?
Oh, they're still over there.
Are they still running?
Fucking cowards!
I ran up there.
I'm gonna run up there.
Hey, they're fighting someone else!
Oh, they're going, they're going, they're going up!
Wait, what?
I hear like, so many gunshots.
Like, here?
Yeah.
And also here?
On that building.
The cracked one?
There's healing.
Aw, I couldn't get him.
We're like, in between a lot of teams.
I don't know.
I don't like this.
Yeah, I don't either.
Okay, let's head over there and see if we can get it there on time.
They're fighting at it.
Don't worry.
We're coming in!
Third party!
Wait, it's gone.
Wait, what the fuck?
Cracked one?
Wait, can we still get there?
What the fuck?
Are they gonna come towards...
No!
It's gone!
But I think we have to run.
Wait, in front of me?
Whoa!
I don't...
I don't like this.
I smoked again for you.
Thank you.
I think we maybe...
Oh, wait.
You got him?
I'm gonna drop down.
I'm gonna drop down from here.
Another squad on him.
That's not good.
I am sliding into the other squad now.
Squadding...
Oh, nice.
Got one.
Wait, he has fucking digi too.
That's illegal.
Oh my god.
I don't know where...
Oh, he's over here.
95?
Flesh?
Does any of them have R9?
Nope.
I'm gonna loot.
I'm gonna...
You'll be fine, right?
You guys will be fine.
He has to go to zone anyway, right?
Yep.
Hey.
What zone is this?
Oh, it's zone 2.
It doesn't matter for him.
Do you have a better light ammo gun?
Hello?
You're not gonna be in zone forever, right?
Come out.
You're really gonna heal in zone?
Wow.
I'm gonna scan real quick.
Yeah, you scan him and see if we can find him.
I don't see him at all right now.
Oh.
Oh, he's all the way over there.
Well, I'm heading over them.
Hello?
Knock knock.
Where are you?
Okay.
Alright.
He got stuck on the car.
Right here.
Okay.
That was a little embarrassing for that man.
Did I last hiding chart right?
Alright.
No problem.
I'm just healing up right now.
I don't think that guy had his driver's license.
Bless you.
I hear people fighting like...
Umm... here.
Yeah, there's like another fight over there.
Alright, you go help Nico.
I'm gonna slowly walk over.
Run over.
Poor guy.
Never got his driver's license.
I'm heading over.
There's another... There's another... There's another...
Oh, that's a replicator.
Nice.
I'm almost there.
You're knocked.
Don't worry.
I'm coming.
Nico!
I need help.
Oh, no!
No!
There's another guy!
Right here.
There's two!
Go me.
There's another team.
There's another team right here.
Don't let them thirst me.
I swear to God.
I have a wingman.
If they thirst me, they take the wingman.
I just need you guys to know that.
They cannot...
They absolutely cannot thirst me.
They absolutely cannot thirst me!
I got them pretty low.
Ahh!
Ah!
That was a little scary.
Wait, go, go, go, go, go.
I'm safe.
I'm so safe.
There's no way.
Really?
You mean it?
Yeah, there's no way.
Provide me.
I have ray guns.
Alright.
Nice, and I can self-heal too.
See?
Easy.
And I'm healing on my...
I'm healing in my smoke too.
Alright.
Are you fucking... Oh my god.
Alright, I'm fine.
I'm okay.
Nobody has a med kid, but I'm okay.
Wait, are they fighting people behind them too?
Or are they just shooting at me?
I think they're shooting at you.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Oh, behind me, behind me, behind me!
I think we gotta back up.
I'm gonna back up fully.
There's too many people on us.
I'm good?
Wait.
I think there's more.
Wait, that's not good.
Where?
Maybe he missed me?
I don't know.
I lied.
You said he hit me 100%.
Okay.
Well, it has to be rat, right?
But men lie all the time, so...
Who hurt you?
Oh my god.
What a statement.
They landed up there.
I see them.
They're right in front of me.
I'm looking.
I'm trying to make sure we don't...
I'm trying to make sure we don't get like...
Uh...
Stealth die.
They're just looking behind us.
See if there's any rats.
Oh, yeah.
I see a rat.
He's gonna come all the way over to us?
I guess he's gonna take the zip on the other side.
I smell it.
Is he?
Oh, there he is.
Wait, it's two!
Well, I missed.
Over here.
He ran into the house.
The other one has to run up normal stairs like a human being.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Last guy is like below us.
He's running all the way across.
He's like running this way.
This is like...
There's like one rat in former squads.
I don't really have an angle on this.
Oh, they're shooting.
They're trying to kill the rat.
They killed the rat.
Rat is dead.
Red armor?
Jesus Christ!
Speak again, idiot.
That's a lot of people.
Where do you guys have medkits?
I have one.
And I have a couple syringes.
Yeah, I need some.
I'm on my way.
Nice.
Here you go.
Alright, so...
Wait, where is zone?
No, they're like right below us.
They're like right below.
There's a whole squad.
A whole squad below us.
Boop!
Oh my god, please!
I don't have figments!
Chill!
I can drop you a bat right here.
Alright, I'll take that after my shield sells.
Or five.
I think it doesn't need to be a Nika.
Yeah, I can just keep this cross.
You go with Nika and I'm just gonna keep this cross.
They're right here.
I wonder if I can nade this.
Or not nade, but ult this.
This.
That should hit them, right?
Gotta make sure they don't climb up.
Oh, hey, I hit one.
There's a team right here, stuck.
I knocked one.
Knocked on!
The guy behind this thing.
Come on!
He has to come over.
Nice.
We're dead.
Are you still in there?
Oh, he is.
I'm on my way, baby girl!
Woah!
Wait, there's a full team over here too!
Oh my god, it's like a pack of rats!
Oh my god.
I knocked one right here.
Nice.
I'm trying to make sure they don't climb up on us.
Go, Niko, go!
Cool.
Wait, are you guys okay?
On us, on us.
I'm coming over.
Oh shit, other team is coming over!
Do you have armor swaps here?
There, there.
Nice, okay.
Nice, that's the core.
I need it.
Don't worry, I have digi.
Wait, there's still one more.
Where the fuck is the last one?
Oh my god, I have purple.
I have nades.
Oh, I thought that was gonna be closer.
I'm going up high ground.
I might be dead doing this.
On me?
Holy shit, what is your strength!
Oh, he's one, he's one!
Right here.
This guy is one!
Go Niko, go Niko!
Nice.
Niko's got this.
He can 1v3.
Believe in Niko!
Glut your carry!
Yeah!
We did it everyone!
Yay!
Let him go!
I knew he got this.
I knew it.
I knew Nico's got this.
This is a Nico cam.
What the fuck?
After all the meds and res I gave you?
Yeah, but like...
But did you kill the last person?
I did actually.
Wait, did you?
I did.
I did like 20 damage to him.
Why are you like FUNS?
Nice.
I did 20 damage to him and I killed him.
Holy shit we got 667 for that.
Why do you keep swapping the genios?
It's a bug.
It's a fucking apex bug that's been in there for like fucking years now.
Alright.
Look at that.
Look at us go.
I knew we could do it.
I knew Nico could do it.
When do we get to play Valorant, Doki?
Sorry, what?
So tomorrow?
Sorry.
What did you say?
Sorry, I have therapy tomorrow.
I have therapy tomorrow.
I know you do, but I know what time you have it at.
I know what time you have it at.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I was in close with you.
I literally heard.
I literally...
I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't know what you're...
Sorry, when did that happen?
So, 9pm Valorant?
Okay, but it's also my dog's birthday.
Okay, how about tonight after your nappy lappy?
Uh...
Hey!
Huh?
All right, LG for me.
LG.
Where are you going?
LG for me.
I'm going to sleep.
What do you mean?
Without me?
Oh, my god!
Look what you did.
My game crashed.
That was a sign.
Without me.
You're dead.
Look what you did.
My game fucking crashed.
Do you know what's the worst part?
You're the jump master.
Oh, wait, that's pretty bad!
Wait, usually it gives the jump master to somebody else if it crashes.
Did you pass it to me?
Did you pass it to me, Glee?
No, I didn't.
Did you pass it to me?
I didn't, because mine automatically passes to Nico.
Then Nico, okay, good.
Nico, pass to you.
We blame it on Nico again.
There's actually enemies here.
Wait, what?
There's people here.
I just... Wait, what?
Wait, what?
I literally... Okay.
I just got back.
Okay, cool, because I landed you in a semi-alright place.
I don't have a gun.
I have an aid.
I got all the attachments.
Shut up!
Shut up, Doki!
Don't talk to me right now!
There's no gun.
I have a Mozambique.
It's okay.
I kicked the bins.
Okay, sir.
Okay, you guys looted that.
Oh no, I'm P20 right now.
I'm gonna run this.
Please have mercy.
Wait, what?
Okay,
that's not LG.
not LG.
Not LG.
Not now, LG.
Look, if I crash, it doesn't count.
I need my nap.
Okay, LG.
Are you a quitter?
It's literally a 40!
Whoa!
Whoa, you gonna let Nico talk shit to you like that?
Wow!
Well, shit, I'm crying now.
Look, it's too done.
I'm crying now.
My allergies.
Oh my god!
Okay, I'm fixed now.
Okay.
I can't believe it.
Ready up, Nico!
Ready up!
Where the fuck is he?
Where did he go?
Where the fuck did Nico go?
All men do is eat hot chip, charge their phone, lie, and abandon us.
Are you okay?
No.
Gumi, who hurt you?
Who hurt you?
You know who hurt me.
Oh, true, true.
You literally know my past.
You know my past.
That's not true.
How... I should say which one.
Oh, you know, that one.
Sorry, they all sort of blurred together.
They're all the same.
They're all the same person.
You know, I don't think I can do it.
I will use a crutch right now.
He's getting water fucking weak.
It's all about being dehydrated.
Okay, don't get dehydrated, guys, when you're gaming.
All of my dreams I spent on you.
So if you need to get this girl a hug or to a cat cafe, she literally has like her dog with her.
She... you can't save her.
Save me, white girl, save me.
Have you seen that photo on Mercy?
Which one?
On Overwatch.
There's so many.
Save me, white girl, save me.
Yeah, come on.
I swear to... I swear to God, if I...
I crashed.
I swear to God.
I swear, I think it's the Jump Master.
There's no way.
It's the Jump Master.
There's no fucking way.
I refuse to believe.
Every time...
Oh my God, Niko's talking shit.
He's like a 40-year-old.
Every time...
Every time I have Jump Master.
I swear to God.
Guys, no.
Don't bully my GPU.
He's shy.
You're making his performance anxiety.
He's trying his best.
Kazoo.
I'm okay.
We have people on us.
Yay, Kazoo.
Yay.
Dude, what's your dog doing?
He's putting his head on my lap.
He's just looking at me.
I'm a multi-billionaire.
I've lost my job.
Ducky, can you pay for my first class tickets to Japan, please?
Wait.
I'm sorry.
I'm a multi-billionaire.
From what?
The guy that, fucking, just met me?
Like four years?
Met me again after four years?
Four years ago.
I heard you're a multi-billionaire.
Can you please buy me a car?
I don't drive.
You should ask Niko.
Nikola Tesla.
I bet Niko has multi-million dollars.
Whoa!
Oh!
Goodbye.
Wow.
I'm fine.
I'm okay.
I don't really want to go back up there.
Oh my god.
Get fucking owned, you freaking noob!
Yeah, bitch.
He'll be fine, right?
You're jumping me though.
Oh shit, he was not fine, guys.
Okay, you rez him?
I got you.
Flesh?
What are you trying to chew?
Like...
What?
I rez'd him.
Come on now.
Alright.
Let's get the ult one.
Easy.
Wait.
Oh, that's our... that's us, NiKo.
NiKo, you're pissing me off.
Yeah, you're pissing us off, NiKo.
Why did I get a bat?
I could've gotten Bear Sableyes.
I'm going back to high ground.
There must be stuff up top.
The loot.
NiKo haters in the lobby.
Heads up, that's me!
Holy shit!
He's just a little guy.
Can't believe it, Goomy.
How dare you.
Found extra supplies.
What has he done for me?
What?
You're right.
You're right, guys.
What has NiKo done for us?
NiKo did nothing wrong.
Wait, but he did help us win last game.
No.
Are you in denial?
I literally got the last kill.
Yeah, like five damage.
What?
Yeah, do you have proof?
You were downed.
You have proof?
You can't say nothing.
Yeah, I have Shadow Play on...
Yeah?
All right, post it.
Post it on Twitter.
Okay, just give me a second.
Yeah, do it.
Do it right now.
I'm literally busy.
I'm playing Apex.
Yeah, do it right now.
You can literally...
We literally have no one here.
I said I'm literally playing Apex.
Don't talk to me.
We literally have no one here.
I can't pause this game.
What don't you understand?
Yes, you can.
We just stand still.
Goomy in denial.
I'm literally playing Apex.
We're all literally playing Apex.
What do you mean?
I'm literally gaming right now.
Where are the people?
Where are the people that's running at us right now?
I could have scanned.
We could scan here.
Is there anyone here?
Oh, wait.
No, there's no map.
There's only map room scans.
No.
There's a scan right there.
You're right.
It's an online game.
We can never pause.
People were here though.
I remember when my mom used to yell at me to pause my game while I was playing.
MapleStory.
Classic.
Classic moms.
Don't you know?
I'm in this field party quest.
And...
Wait, there's like people to our right.
Clearly to our right.
They're like shooting at each other.
Why did I see someone in your chat asking if my mom was single?
Ami?
Cracked?
32 flesh?
Right here?
Oh my gosh.
Champion's dead.
He's scared.
Jump over.
Trust me.
Jump over here.
There's someone right up here!
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
That was my bad.
I should not have told you to jump over.
That was...
Wait!
That's another team!
That's another team.
Woo!
Oh, Nico.
No, don't.
Nico, don't die.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Alright.
This is awkward.
Oh, this is awkward.
Wait!
He...
Oh my god!
I have to reload!
Fuck!
I didn't even realize.
Woohoohoo!
Wait, that's part of his team?
I thought it was a third!
Third party!
This is a little awkward, guys.
You know what?
I can leave, right?
Oh, fuck!
No!
His teammate came behind me!
That was a terrible ulti.
That was a terri... You know what?
We'll do another one.
JK.
This...
LOL.
This is LG.
He seemed a little too excited there.
Whoa!
Calm down, Nico!
Timber down, man.
LOL.
What is he doing taking conduit?
What is he doing?
I think he called your skin ugly.
Wait, what?
Better skin.
How dare you?
This is the classic pink skin.
Where the comms at?
LOL.
Me.
Maybe.
Don't give me jump.
Or I crack.
Yeah.
There is a... There is a pattern.
LOL.
We figured out a pattern.
I crash when I get jumpmaster.
LOL.
Alright.
Where the fuck is the last two players?
You said I'm giving you jump?
That's fucked up, Nico.
I can't believe it.
I'm ready to stone.
We're never playing with Nico ever again.
LOL.
Cause, do you know what?
If you ever wanna play with Doki and I, you have to be jumpmaster.
Exactly.
You know what?
Yeah.
Tell that to him.
Right?
Right now.
Say it.
Nico?
Come on.
Use your words.
You're not gonna play with us ever again if you're not jumpmaster.
LOL.
I used my wits.
We only play with people who are jumpmaster.
Did you get that?
LOL.
Do you understand me?
Shit.
You're like a...
Yes, ma'am.
LOL.
You're like a mob boss.
There we go.
Yeah, that's what we thought.
That's what we thought.
Oh my god, what happened to you, Gu?
You changed.
I played League of Legends.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I play League of Legends every day.
And Valorant?!
Are you okay, like, mentally?
I'm surprised you do two of them at the same time.
In front of us!
Oh, Gu!
I got you.
I cracked one of them.
I cracked the other.
Cracked one?
Yeah, that's right.
Run, bitch.
Yeah.
Bitch?
Yeah, wait.
They're pulling up in the whippy!
Wait, I think that's the nerf.
Last one?
Wait, is that the same?
Okay, yeah, he is.
I hear someone to my right.
Yeah, here.
Oh, nice.
Niko got it.
Nice!
We all got it!
Yeah, Diane!
Be Betty.
Yeah!
Diane!
Come back.
Someone does not like Diane.
We got two parts!
What even is in the care package anyway?
F screws!
Grabbing a vault Prowler.
No long range, which isn't ideal.
I have a hemlock, anyone trade?
Yeah, I'll trade it.
I'll trade it for Prowler.
Nice.
I'm grabbing the... What?
Oh!
Guess I'm not grabbing the fucking bat.
On my ping.
No, my battery!
My battery for my white armor!
Where is it?
I don't know, did I pick it up?
He's over there.
So far.
Oh my god, they have like a little head glitch area.
Wingman, Eva, Bow and Kraber.
Oh, they just took away the Prowler for the Eva 8.
I see them.
They're all over there.
I had no red just now.
No, he knows I have white.
What?
He knows I have white.
Oh!
Shit!
That like, booted me off almost.
I thought you were Chinese.
I'm not going to die.
I'm going to die.
I see that light.
Okay, I don't... I don't have shields anymore.
They took everything from me.
Cracked the caustic and went up there.
Alright, I'm going to... I'm fucked.
I am so fucked.
Oh, I'm going to bat with my white armor.
Is this... is this ours?
I can't tell.
Girl, do we look like we have a Bangalore?
Yes, we do!
What do you mean?
Oh, what the fuck?
Moneko changes every time I look at him!
Does it look like we have a Bangalore?
I'm fucked.
Okay, I'm fucked.
I got shot from the back.
Wait, are you alive?
I am very afraid for your life right now.
I do not... shit!
You are 100% fucked right now.
You know what?
We can do one more game.
Oh, literally, what the fuck?
You know what?
I can do one more.
I can keep going.
The ride never ends.
Doki, are you getting me flowers tomorrow?
What?
Shouldn't you be getting my dog flowers?
I would if you gave me your new address when I asked for it.
I did!
I sent you...
You literally never did!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm gonna type for it.
I'm gonna leave my text.
No, no, no, no, I did.
I did.
I remember.
I remember texting you my address.
You never did.
I did!
I remember.
I did.
I 100% did.
I remember.
It's right there.
Where's right there?
It's literally right there.
It's right there.
Right where?
It's... it's... okay, that's not my fault you're blind.
Okay, maybe... I think I deleted it after.
Look, someone... what if someone random sees it?
What if you have your, like, Discord or phone open?
And it always sees it?
I must have deleted it.
Who's gonna look at my phone?
I... what?
I don't know!
Someone that steals your phone?
And they're gonna look for wife number four, specifically?
And send them my text messages for wife number four?
Yeah, cause they're gonna be like, what the fuck is wife number four?
Oh, so I'm number four?
I've known you for seven years.
I've known you for 7 years!
I've known you for 7 years and I'm wife number 4?!
Let's not pay attention to that.
What do you mean let's not pay attention to that?!
I'm gonna die because I'm wife number 4!
This is your fault!
I got too distracted for being wife number 4.
I'm wife number 4.
Who's number 3?
Give me the name right now!
Her name is Rose.
Who the fuck is Rose?
My wife.
Who the fuck?
How long has she known you?
Since 2014.
We got this.
2013?
Over a decade.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wife number 2.
Um...
Christina?
Alright, how many years?
Preschool.
What the fuck?!
Alright, wife number 1.
Priscilla?
How long?
Before we were even born.
Alright, now you're...
Now I know for fucking sure all these wives are not Now I know you're making shit up.
They're real!
They're not real.
There's no fucking way.
One to three are ten plus years.
In a row?
Three in a row.
I have friends.
Alright, wife number 1.
Who?
Who is wife number 1?
I literally told you Priscilla!
You said like you've known her since like fucking before you were born.
That doesn't make sense.
We're families!
We knew each other before we were born!
Oh!
So it wasn't by choice.
...
Are you saying I was in an arranged marriage?
Oh my god, did you know my mom almost put me in an arranged marriage when I was young?
Yeah, Priscilla!
...
Alright, well now I know.
Now I know.
I could never win over Priscilla.
Girl, you literally put me as Cali girl number 4 or something last time.
...
I did not put you as number 4!
I just...
I didn't even have a number.
You were the first one.
...
I'm the original Cali girl?
You're the original Cali girl!
And so, wife number 4.
Well, now I know...
...
who favors who in this friendship.
You literally held me gunpoint to bring back the puke emote.
...
What do you mean?
It's called a deal.
...
It's called a business deal.
Where'd that Ball Eldrin from the business deal go?
...
fine!
I'm gonna die...
I'm already dead!
I'll save you, my Princess!
Thank you!
Cali girl!
Go, Cali girl!
...
... ... Oh...
... I see you downed already.
... I see you...
Go, Cali girl!
Okay, we're fine.
Nico will be fine.
See, Nico got it!
Is that everybody?
Nice.
I missed when like... everybody in our lobby was clearly bronze.
Or rookie.
I missed that.
When the people get better.
I like how someone was like, yes I have a wife, she goes to a different school.
Yeah, you don't know her.
Yeah, you just never met her, you know?
Nico is like... what did Nico do?
Nico didn't save our lives.
Today, like in this game.
He's literally some guy.
Wake up.
Why did you say that about us?
We're literally some girls?
How are we different?
They're simping over some guy.
How are we different, Gumi?
Wake up.
Gumi, how are we different from Nico?
Other than the fact that he's a guy.
And has a dick.
Okay, simmer down, wife number four.
Oh shit!
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry I never talked back to you.
Simmer down.
I'm sorry.
Please.
Don't do it.
Don't lock me in that room again.
I'm sorry.
I got the white tank top on.
Oh no!
Holy fuck!
This is why Nico is better than us.
He would never.
Never get the chance to.
I don't wanna hear it.
Nico, please save us.
Back in the room.
Back in the room, filthy bird.
Oh my god.
What happened to you, Gumi?
I play Rayna and Valorant.
Oh shit!
Guys, this is not Dommie Mommie.
Guys, if you think this is Dommie Mommie, please.
Please.
You need my therapist.
There are some issues to unpack there.
There is a lot of issues we need to work on.
I play Jett and Valorant.
Oh my god.
You're Jett daddy.
Call me Jetta.
This is why I never play Valorant.
I cannot do it.
Oh god.
My head hurts.
The E-couples and Valorant.
It's like Overwatch walked so Valorant could run.
Do you need a cam?
Hold on.
What?
Nothing.
Don't worry, wife number four.
What?
Number four?
Don't worry, wife number four.
I'll save you, my queen.
What?
Get down, wife number four.
You're like, today I'll choose you, wife number four.
Oh, wife number two.
Go back.
Go back into the chamber.
Today is wife number four's day time.
No, you say.
Oh shit, there's people there.
No!
Guys, okay.
Oh, it's my discord.
Oh, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I thought my game crashed, but my discord crashed.
My discord crashed.
It's okay.
I'm fine.
I thought it was my apex.
Whoa, what?
Oh, fuck.
Oh, I'm getting dead slides.
I'm gonna cover you, rez.
It'll be fine.
There's two teams.
Nico, you're dead.
Oh, it's just a concubine.
Whoa!
He's a side chick, if you will.
No!
My chat.
My chat's gonna be so angry.
What the fuck is...
Wait, where are they?
What the fuck?
My discord keeps crashing.
Oh, no.
Are you okay?
No, my discord keeps crashing.
My toaster is overheating.
Oh, my god.
I'm sorry, Nico can get me over there.
Don't worry.
Save me.
Oh, my god.
I'll calm down.
Maybe it is a PC problem.
Get it.
Maybe...
You know...
It's okay.
Maybe it is a PC issue.
I don't know.
I can't tell yet.
I'll say it.
Say what?
Nico is but a mashed potatoes and you're the steak to me.
You're the main dish.
Wait, then what's wife number one?
If... If I...
If I am the steak, then what's wife number one?
Huh?
You're gonna hate to hear this.
I think you need to cover your...
No.
I can take it.
I actually don't like meat that much.
And I don't really like steak that much.
Um...
What?
Wait...
I...
Then what's mashed potatoes to you?
I don't even like potatoes that much either.
Oh, saying so...
I will not go turn the lights off.
I can't believe it.
I...
Do I mean nothing to you?
I prefer seafood and mostly chicken.
I prefer mostly Asian foods.
I'm not even seafood?
You can...
See my food?
I don't know what that means.
Okay.
Oh, right there!
Cracked him?
Knock?
I got you.
I'm gonna push up a little.
I might be doing something stupid.
I think someone just threw a nade at me.
Oh, I did...
I cracked him!
Oh, I did something stupid!
I got shot in my asshole!
It's okay.
Nico can res me.
Oh, he's so fucking dead.
I...
I got beamed so fucking hard.
There is a team right there on you, Kumi.
So, I'm just gonna crawl to Nico cause I think he can...
Oh, wait!
You did it!
Kumi!
I'm so safe.
I'm so safe, Kumi.
I swear to God.
I have never been this safe before.
Alright.
I'm gonna go.
Nice.
You know what...
There's a kill swap here.
Alright, nice.
I'm gonna...
Okay, I sort of egoed somebody way too hard.
I thought...
I thought I could live that.
I like how...
I like how you didn't res me and Nico res me.
Girl, I was fighting for my life!
I like...
You tried to confirm your safety.
I bet if I was wife number one, you would res me instantly.
I...
I don't know.
I have a feeling.
It's just a little feeling I have.
That was the fucking biggest nade I've ever seen.
They cooked that shit up!
I think we should head to Nico.
Go!
Okay, give me your shield.
Give me your shield.
Okay.
I'm so dead.
Nico, no!
Nico!
Oh, okay.
Why are you still in bronze?
We gave you five hours!
You know, I can do one more.
I can do another one.
Who the fuck are you talking to?
The guy that killed us!
They were in Prince Town!
Oh.
We gave you five hours to climb out of bronze.
Oh, okay.
I can't do nothing.
I think my PC is overheating because it's so fucking hot.
Wait!
My window's closed again!
Oh my god!
My PC's hot too!
Wait!
I think my mom closed the window.
Let me open it again.
My room's 69 degrees!
I...
We're good.
Dude, my room is 20 degrees right now.
Celsius.
My room's like super fucking hot right now.
I need to like buy a fan for my room.
I have like a heater for my room, but I don't have a fan.
I...
Okay.
This is LG for reals.
For real, real.
I promise.
One off, bro.
One off.
What?
What the fuck?
Am I a full aircon?
I do, but like, um, my room is literally...
I...
It's a box.
It's like a...
Anyway, I'm booting up my game back.
Niko!
It's like a greenhouse, because there's like five windows surrounding my room.
Two of the walls is like windows.
So, it's like literally the sun shines in.
And then it's a fucking greenhouse.
So, it's not great.
You're just like my beautiful flower for real.
Yay!
I'm a dying flower.
Yeah, it's like a sun room.
It's so bad.
It's either way too hot or way too fucking cold.
There's no in between.
Oh my god, we're here!
Gumi, you're jump master.
There's a team here.
Where are we going?
Where?
Are we going here?
Shitloon?
I don't know.
Someone pinged it.
I guess we go here.
No one else landed here, so we should be safe.
Alright.
LG for real.
No joke.
Please, I need to take a nap.
No joke this time, for real.
Don't worry, I yelled at Niko for you.
Oh, you did?
Thanks.
Yeah.
Yeah, but you might as well do it again.
Teach him a lesson.
No, I'm a nice person.
Screw you, Niko.
Well, who said that?
Who said
that?
Oh my god.
Was your window open?
Was your window open, Gumi?
Guys, I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Don't turn around.
Don't turn.
Did you see that ghost?
Don't look back.
Kinito?
Oh, Kinito.
Alright, I'm ready to fight.
Alright, this is LG for reals.
No more, no more not LG.
No more fake outs.
I'm for real LG.
I've never been so LG in my life.
Who the fuck scanned this?
There's people over here.
Let's go.
Go.
Sorry, Niko.
I'm just cranky.
I haven't had my afternoon nap.
Say it in voice.
Apologize to him right now.
Niko.
Die.
Never do that again in front of me.
Never do that.
Oh my god.
I feel so tired.
Cracked.
One more.
Shatter the prey's shield.
He ran.
He's running like a little baby.
Woah.
Go, Niko.
Go.
Oh.
Where are they?
They ran down.
Did they run all the way down?
Wait, there's a wench.
They didn't run all the way down.
Liar.
Wait, there's one right here.
Right here.
Oh.
Bumi, no.
Don't die.
There's one on me too.
Oh, I'm dead.
No.
I didn't get my one.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm dead because of your run.
Maybe I'm also tired.
I'm healing.
It's fine.
I believe.
Look.
He had a destructor.
Look, all I'm saying is if I had his same loadout, I would have been alive.
That's all I'm saying.
I believe you wholeheartedly.
No, wait.
I'm going to lead.
I swear... watch.
I'm gonna become the seer.
Okay, I might be dead cuz...
Okay, yeah, I'm 100% dead.
I'm so fucked.
Please, someone defend me.
I'm streaming.
I'm streaming, defend me!
Where's his loadout?
Wait...
Where is his loadout?
Where is the guy?
Come here, come here.
Where the fuck is the guy that killed...
There he is.
Alright.
Who shot us earlier?
Oh, he's over there.
Okay.
I didn't want to fight in zone, but I guess we will.
I cracked one.
Well, I'm outside of zone.
Oh, you guys are so balls deep.
Yep.
Um...
I don't know how...
They're flush.
I'm gonna go to zone.
Wait, what?
Oh, hey, I got a kill!
I did that.
You smile.
Hey, it was me, smile.
See, I told you.
The moment I take this man's loadout, I win.
Even though he died by ring.
No...
He might be...
Like a me-o.
I thought he was just gonna take the car and then come back here.
Oh, wait.
Why are they all dying to ring?
Do they not have heals?
Probably not.
I guess not.
Oh, bastards alert!
Oh, I'm coming over.
Bastard alert, Nico.
Get him.
Where are they?
Alright, I opened the door so they all know we're here now.
Oh, shit.
Wait, where are they?
Okay.
Okay, I have white armor.
I'm a little scared.
Um, there's that team behind us as well, so we gotta be careful.
Pushing up.
Nico just ate one of my shots.
There's a guy right here in front of me.
Knocked one.
Knocked two.
There's still one more guy.
Whoa.
Where is he?
There.
See, I told you.
My loadout.
There's still more.
I know, I know.
Cover, cover.
I have gold.
I knew it.
I knew my loadout is a he.
I don't have any long range, so I require you guys to do all the long range for me.
Where's your teammate?
Oh, my God, he's in front of you.
I can't cancel it.
Oh, my God.
What?
Hey, I'm here.
Can I get to you?
Wait, what?
Is that another team?
Yeah, the other team was here a little bit too long ago.
Wait, I hear people.
Wow, shit!
Hello.
There you go.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
It's all about this new loadout.
Oh, I just realized I haven't upgraded at all.
What do people use?
Increase attack roll range, gain attack with charge, but have shield regen duration.
Wait, which one is good for conduit?
Split charge or radiant transfer?
Chat!
Backseat time!
I haven't had time to learn meta!
Oh my god, too many.
Which one?
Which one guys?
Probably transfer?
Getting!
That one?
Guys!
Oh wait, there's someone in front of us.
There's a team here.
Oh, I can shield them both in the first one!
You're right!
Okay.
It's a caustic in there.
I kinda don't wanna go in there.
It's too late.
I'm going in.
Girl, I literally see you walking up to the entrance.
You can turn around.
I'm going in.
I ulted.
What are you gonna do?
Kill us?
See?
Look, we're fine.
Oh!
Whoops.
Oh my god, okay.
Oh, there's his ult coming in!
Come on, get over here, Niko!
Are they running from us?
They're running from us.
Oh, Niko, I don't have...
Niko, please.
Niko, please!
Oh, there's a guy there!
He's still there.
I'll run.
I cover, I'll cover.
You rez?
I can cover.
I cannot cover anymore.
Here.
I gave it to the wrong person.
We knocked one.
Unless he rez.
He rez.
Please, get closer.
I only have short range.
I have a Rita plant if we need it.
We're linched zone though.
I don't think...
I'm gonna get a cross.
Oh, nevermind.
I can't get the cross.
I'm gonna bat and you bat.
You fucking kidding me?
I'm batting now.
I'm worried about our backs though, to be fair.
I knocked one.
62 acoustic.
I'm pushing up.
Flash.
He's running.
He's running like a little bitch.
Wait, it's two.
Oh, I need a bat then.
He's full running.
Niko's got it.
I knew it.
I could always believe in Niko.
What are they...
What are they doing?
They're so scared.
Go, Mi.
Run after him.
Jump.
I'm running!
Where did he go?
I'm gonna craft.
Where did...
Wait, where the fuck did he go?
He disappeared.
Wait, what?
I hear something.
Oh, there he is.
Wait, is he dead?
Oh, he's dead.
To the ring.
Dead.
Wait, that's the team that tried to kill us last time in the original house.
Do you know what the...
You know when we were at the...
The little...
The towers?
That was them.
They just finished the fight.
They just finished...
That's the last two.
Last two squads.
Go, go, go, go.
I'm here.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I don't know if this is gonna hit, but I'm gonna hell marry this.
It'll be so smart.
Trust me.
It was definitely not close to anybody.
Did you see me?
I cracked one.
The ring's on neighbor.
I'm gonna go first this guy.
Oh, shit!
Anyway.
Am I left?
Behind this?
On me?
Nice.
What?
Oh, that's bad.
Oh, over there!
Wait, what?
What is happening?
They're super spread.
That's what's happening.
Is this shield slugging?
I'm gonna come up here.
That's fine.
I cover.
Yeah, they're so far.
They're so far.
I took the shield swap.
Holy shit, they're so far.
Poor guy.
I'm gonna...
I'm going in!
No regrets!
I'm in!
Okay, maybe a little regret.
Okay, little regret.
Little regret.
Miko's got this.
Little Miko's got this.
Okay, okay.
All right.
I'm in!
That's huge.
Look at that.
Yay!
I knew this was the real LG!
Me too!
We did it!
Bench time!
Yay!
Goodnight!
Good night, Goomy.
Thanks for playing with me.
See you for Valorant tonight.
Huh?
What?
For Valorant at 9 p.m.?
Oh, bye!
Sorry, you're breaking up on me.
Sorry.
I'm not breaking up with you.
Sorry, sorry, you're...
You're sorry to call.
There's something wrong with the...
Oh, beep, boop, beep!
Hey,
that was fun!
I had a great time.
I really enjoyed it.
Shoutout to...
Shoutout to Gumi for...
playing some games with me.
And also, we finally...
we reunited with Niko from four years ago.
That was actually crazy when he was like, we used to play together in season three.
I was like, whoa!
I played with a lot of people in season three!
Sorry, Niko.
That was crazy.
But yeah, shoutout to Gumi for...
hanging out with me today.
And...
It was just really nice to just...
you know...
pew-pew and have fun and just...
not think about...
anything.
You know?
It's just...
It's...
It was really nice.
I really did...
enjoy it.
But yeah, I hope this was like...
a nice time to just...
you know...
just laugh and have fun and...
forget about what's going on in the world...
for a brief moment.
And I enjoyed my time!
Thank you everybody for hanging out!
It really made me...
very happy.
Gaming and Apex is such a huge...
comfort for me.
Especially when...
you know...
when things aren't looking great for me...
when...
mentally...
I really just...
It's just nice to just...
hang out with friends and...
be able to...
you know...
play Apex and not forget...
what's going on.
And just...
you know...
have some fun and laugh.
And I really appreciate everybody for hanging out with me.
Um...
even though this isn't really...
is not monetized or anything...
I didn't want to...
receive any monetization.
I just want to hang out and...
enjoy my time with...
my friends.
Um...
But yeah!
I had a great time guys.
Um...
I guess...
uh...
Thank you everybody!
Um...
As always everyone...
stay hydrated...
posture check...
get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me...
head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye!